all right
and we are live the last word with lord
cognito ibantus thai guy travis fresh on
that thursday evening campfire good to
be back at the campfire how we doing man
what's going on with you doing good um
yeah got some nice news in the twab this
week been playing a little iron banner
uh bungee made a nice move in guardian
games that was good to see
uh jumped into the first hour of tunic
which was cool um
i have no idea how long that game is in
the first hour i rang one bell if you
know what that means you may know but
i was like so far it was like i played
elden ring it was like like 113 hours
put a pin in that and i was like all
right i need a couple small pallet
cleansers i have a few of in mind and
that was the first one i jumped into
like just the industry one night uh it
was nice uh that fox is ridiculously
adorable and cute and i can see where
there's but the combat definitely is
gonna be i'm gonna see probably a couple
challenging moments there's gonna be a
boss or two that'll probably annoy me
nothing like melania or anything but it
should be fun but overall just been kind
of jamming in the last couple weeks of
the season as we cannot wait for what's
coming soon and they are holding it all
close to their chest but we'll get to
that so what about you travis what have
you been up to man reviewing all the
worst games that are made
how dare you sir um yeah i'm actually
i'm reviewing uh evil dead the game
right now i think i mentioned that last
week maybe i didn't
but yeah that's the one i'm working on
now uh should have that up
uh end of next week i'm hoping i would
i'd like to we got code super late which
is sometimes not a good sign but it is
an online multiplayer game so it's like
if i had to get my guess for a rating on
that and i'm just going to throw it out
into the universe i'm going to guess
have you seen gameplay of it or you just
no i have not i'm just going to guess
the six that's all i'm going to guess
we'll see
just because it's an isometric
multiplayer and i
have little faith in those so
we'll see how it goes no comment no
comment
shout out to nba embargoes
oh what's up tomorrow i guess the
embargo must be soon embargo will be
soon so uh
he's saying 0 out of 10 just because i'm
reviewing it thanks g-man i mean that's
it's a two to three 2.5 out of 10 that's
what it's going to be so yeah
yeah i had a meeting with mitchell
saltzman i was in a meeting with him a
couple days ago and
uh
i pointed out that in that last month he
reviewed one game that was equal in
score to three of the games
[Laughter]
wow oh he just did uh salt and sacrifice
didn't he
yeah he did yeah he gets all the good
ones
um
rogue legacy too as well another game
i'm really enjoying that i do want to
try it that's kind of on my list to give
an attempt to super fun super fun a
little grindy but yeah i'm playing that
when i have time and uh obviously
playing destiny got all my iron banner
stuff done uh
i i guess the the guardian games quest
isn't really mandatory since it just
skips you forward five steps if you
don't complete the ones from the
previous week because
i didn't do really any guardian games
last week and i yeah it's on a weekly
basis that's six and i was like
yeah okay so i was waiting for this yes
like weekly based and the score is
weekly based so like if whatever
happened last week you were gonna get
bumped to week two no matter what
yeah so not really feeling guardian
games this year
kind of feels like there's not a lot to
do but i did enjoy iron banner i played
a lot of crucible um what's the loadouts
looking like what you we're shooting out
there
what's the loadout
you can probably guess one of mine
oh yeah wait did you bring it back to oh
damn vaughn do it
is insidious is in there
the only issue is i've actually been
trying to mess around with the title
just to use ever since we got it that
gun feels better than the numbers show i
will say i've actually been getting some
decent work in on it finally got a
couple good rolls and then paired with
that i've been running
peace of mind up on the top
or honestly
i'm still jamming on my syncopation that
i've been using since like day one and
which queen i like my syncopation so
pulses of course but actually getting
around was like
sidearms are kind of meta right now
they're they're really damn good
um
shotguns a little bit fusion rifles are
kind of op i'm trying to stay away from
those because they feel cheesy um but
i actually have just been challenging
myself to go get through all my red
weapons i have a bunch of red frames and
so i've just been going in a crucible
with like three random loadouts i can
win yeah get a little random
if you can make it make it work not a
bad way to mix it up yeah like every
three matches you get all your all three
of the frames done you know even if
you're not getting heavy kills because
you get progress just for complete
matches uh on your heavy weapons so it's
a pretty good way to do things so i
actually managed to get through i think
all of them after playing like a bunch
on on tuesday so uh that was pretty cool
but yeah i'm done with the iron band
request line and all that so i'm
probably gonna
um i don't know i guess take a break for
a couple weeks wait for the new season
just wait yeah wait wait for monday or
tuesday and then obviously it's news
central so we'll be there for sure yeah
what about you
do you find time for
how's today been
for me
honestly it's not been much destiny at
all sadly but um
yeah it's just been so much going on
with news and obviously we know what
broke today is reference to xbox and
starfield and red fall so it had to
double up on duke
that better be up like tomorrow i gotta
watch
it's been it's processing so we got it
done we'll have some fresh opinions
of raw uh reactions uh to the news so
it'd be good to do you guys record that
reaction before he did his reaction solo
yes okay so yours is even a hotter take
than yeah because i i woke him up with
the news okay yeah yeah i was like he
needs to get up once he sleeps till the
afternoon oh he's he's a fan he's a
vampire he's like he's like how i used
to be so um yeah i've been doing that
plaque can't talk about one game that
i'm playing but the other thing is i
because of that game i took me away from
trek to yomi which i'm like very early
in but i was really getting into it
shout out to travis's review i want to
shout you out man that was excellent
excellent review i watched the video one
i really enjoyed it gave me a nice feel
of that so that's that but um look we've
been rambling long enough
we got a we got a special guest here
exactly waiting patiently you know what
i mean we've got to bring them in a
little bit let's officially start the
podcast now yeah let's do that welcome
to the last word episode number 197
the this week the hype for seasonal
redacted still redacted by the way got a
bit louder and our first new map in
years is coming to destiny 2 and a new
game mode but not too much of that but
we'll get to that in a minute more
changes are coming to pvp next season
man do we have the right guest to talk
about all things crucible our guest
tonight is one of true focus while he
may not have played that many different
games he does like to go full send on
the ones that he does from rts mmorpgs
and now destiny each one of those games
has tons of systems optimizations builds
and play styles to learn that's what
makes our guests so good at what he does
he can take a complicated game like
destiny 2 and make a guide that will
help you with some of the simplest yet
most important things that can help you
be a better player in every facet of the
game outside of having some epic tier
lists and true myth but must myth buster
prowess if you don't learn something
after watching one of his playstyle
guides you really were not paying
attention so
let's welcome a man who never likes to
take as i take his eye off the target
and god forbid his eye is on you because
you're gonna be dead
someone who understands the psyche of
each guardian all too well and someone
you know has so many crucible medals
that they truly had need to invent more
before he gets any new ones a leader at
team synergy recently passed a hundred
thousand subs on his youtube channel
full-time content creator and man of
true focus just check his advanced gg
collection the one the only shadow how
you doing man
wow nice intro thank you so much it's
good to be here dude thank you
we are happy to have you man
shadow in the campfire man we got to get
into it man like
four i know we got to get the destiny
stuff but i got to get the history stuff
so not too many games but i noticed rts
which i thought was interesting like
what kind of gravitated towards you
towards those type of games and also
any any turn based or just strictly rts
um i i think i played a little bit of
civilization which was turn-based um but
mostly rts and i guess i just kind of
got into them because my dad was when i
was really little and he kind of
introduced me to them so that that was
kind of where i got my start in gaming i
guess you could say and i played those
for a few years and eventually moved on
to other games but yeah that was kind of
where i started out so was it age was
the hook like ajay pie is yeah i think
that was probably the first one that i
got into
got it got it guys it's a classic was it
was it three that you played because i
played agent cars two grown up a ton
i've played three i'd i've never played
two actually even though i know that one
is rather popular among the hardcore age
of empires fans so it was just when i
got into the same thing it's like it's
probably just what was that when you got
into them for sure
yeah sure and then um
one question before i get back to you
and then transition
this is unique now the wow
i i gotta ask the while because
wild community is very distinct that
that's a community so it's like how did
that start before all the destiny stuff
too
um i i think a few of my friends played
it in school and we would play it
together and do like raids and stuff um
and then eventually i just got really
into wow and like became like a
competitive raider so
that was pretty fun i i was i don't know
i i don't remember exactly but i think i
placed
pretty highly in a few like competitions
and stuff so that was fun um but i guess
i don't know i still a fairly casual
gamer at that point but that was
probably the first game that i was
the most invested into what expansions
were you
i guess part of because it's been going
on for way too long now
so i think i got into it towards the
beginning of miss of pandaria and then i
played wad and
i quit during the beginning of legion i
believe
okay
so some of the more recent ones
yeah yeah
nice i was not an og player from back in
the day but uh you know that's just
probably makes us tell our age and we're
old so that's all that really means
no doubt no doubt
i also didn't play games as a like a
really little kid yeah it didn't sound
like it really yeah i was i was fairly
like restricted when it comes to
technology when i was really young so i
didn't really get into these things
until i was like middle school
no but
it felt like it no i'm just kidding
but yeah i i it was i didn't really get
into anything until like middle school
high school
um and yeah so now i'm i've graduated
high school a few years ago just for
context
oh
you just got your first beverage are we
that age sure oh i'm 21. so yeah oh okay
yeah come back you got to call it you at
the door sir i don't know
that baby face is working real hard on
him 21 and you're not on camera man come
on you got the most less the least
wrinkly face in the group and you're
high how do you let's see how do you let
all of these mugs
show up you come on what are we doing
let's see he's keeping it to his
namesake shadow i believe
keeping it low
he should have done he should have done
the uh the black outline with the
monster's voice like a light behind him
so it's just a silhouette
tell us what you like face
in one of my videos i i showed a video
of my hands on the controller to like
like reference something and people are
like oh my gosh shadow hands reveal your
hand's confirmed
that's like one of those random things
especially when you've got as far as you
are
uh i did mine on when i got to do a cool
guest spot but it was more it gets to be
a point where you go long enough and
you're like do i ever show it or is
there a point in doing it or then it's
like when i do it it's not it's never
going to be like good enough but yeah
it's i don't know it's kind of it's kind
of weird i i just i just don't have a
camera and i don't want to use like my
really crappy like laptop webcam or
anything like that so i mean i think i'm
probably just gonna invest to get like a
nice camera eventually but yeah um i i
just haven't really had a reason to just
because the type of content doesn't that
i make doesn't necessitate having a
camera and i don't stream all that often
so
um but yeah we'll see i mean that could
always change in the future
no doubt no doubt so you're coming from
wow
you got all you know kind of casually
into it in this destiny thing how's this
yeah
i have a really funny story about this
actually so i was actually just talking
to one of my friends that i've known
since i was like four and he and another
one of my friends
went in to buy me destiny 1 as a
birthday present in 2014
and i at the time i was just like i
wasn't really that into it because i was
still playing wow but then a few years
later i actually got into destiny and
have been playing ever since so it's
actually wild to me because like if that
never if that didn't happen if they
didn't give that to me as a birthday
present i probably never would have
gotten into this game
and
yeah it's lit it's literally kind of
crazy to think about because i mean it
has become my job at this point so
crazy crazy crazy and uh
hunter maine
i will say like yes
two titans one warlock but
like i'm glad to have a hunter on the
podcast for balance sometimes we need
you guys in here even though we can't
keep your feet on the floor so
yeah
speaking about it i mean as you were
just saying i mean i couldn't
i couldn't be a shadow and not be in the
invis hunter so
far
good job also shadow is your name
because you're currently living in the
warlock and titan shadow and gorilla
games
hey i mean you know that's totally fine
with me you can you can shoot the
warlocks and the titans while i sit
behind them and snipe you it's fine with
me
cannon fodder and you'd be like i'll
just
watch
and i'll wait until they're in in my
sniper scope
i'll hide behind the beefy titan it
sounds like a good game plan honestly
yeah it's the last surface area yeah i
was gonna say those those shoulder pads
are about building wide so you got some
room back there to move around
okay getting no go ahead you're good no
i'll just just say one of the videos i
really appreciate that you made is um
kind of like the different stages of a
destiny player and it is so
hilarious it is that like that wonder
phase and they're just getting into it
and then you see the advancement of it
and it's just like i think the funny
thing is when you the try hard
that was hilarious like tell me like the
construction of that video and was it
all based off of personal experience or
observation of like friends and
different players that get into the game
oh it was a combination of everything i
try to do a lot of research for every
video i make and this one was no
exception so it was it was some personal
experience some asking friends so i'm
asking like my community my discord
server instant people like that just to
try to get as many wide opinions as i
can because i ultimately for that video
i wanted to create something that was
accurate for the largest number of
people possible i mean obviously not
every single destiny player
can be fit into the 10 stages of
progression in the video but i wanted to
just make like a really entertaining and
typical and like relatable 10 stages so
love it i just kind of researched
everything and used my own personal
experience with the game and my friends
and yeah for everybody i mean
i'm sorry one last yeah i know i'm
interrupted but
my personal
is the return
because they talk all that and then they
come right back and then you say y'all
this new content new expansion new
marketing trailer new vicious and all
that go out the window so i was like
yeah that is accurate because i know
those dudes sorry it's good i had to
give them props on the return that was
like the one for me specifically on the
hunter one that you did like that the
stages of being a hunter number three is
too amazing you're like oh i've learned
how to dodge load into the game dodge
shoot my gun dodge
oh there's an enemy dodge
i was like is just ingrained into the
hunter brain you can't not dodge cool
down is up dodge why just to dodge
no it was like that was just the way all
the different little examples was
it was
it's it's a really cool way that you'll
like make fun of something like that but
everybody's like yep 100 accurate i i
feel like i've been called out but i
can't say it's wrong so
now for me is um
one of the cool things that i like what
you've done is
like one of the ones that really i think
caught my eye a while ago just took a
while to get you on is the 40-60 rule
and then just some of those things to
help you in pvp is like it's the idea of
changing the way you think about a game
and changing the way you think about
your engagements changing the way you
look at the environment changing your
placement and all those little things
that you as a high-level pvp player
obviously know when you hear like a high
skill people talk you're like yeah these
guys know exactly what they're doing but
it's just the way you can phrase
something to make somebody realize be
like 40 cover 60
you know environment with somebody in
front of you like that's something
somebody can
wrap their head around and i really like
the way that you did that so it's like
when you were going through like your
top 10 things to improve your kd
um as travis i'll beat you too at this
time we have a long running segment on
air here
where
where certain content creators will help
me specifically since i am the pvp
schlub
try and get a little better at the game
so i know i've seen those couple so if
i've seen those two i've seen the 4060
and i've seen you know some of those
things to improve your kd what is one of
those like
a little more nuanced things that you
would say is still universally
applicable that's going to help somebody
improve their crucible performance
um i don't know i i guess probably
positioning i guess it is related to the
46 year old but not necessarily the same
thing um
i think like the the number one thing
that people look over is positioning
relative to teammates positioning
relative to cover and positioning
relative to the opponent's spawn um
because a lot of people will play really
aggressively near the spawn and no
matter how many enemies you kill they're
just gonna spawn right back up if you're
in 6v6 right so if you're playing up
towards the spawn you're kind of
screwing yourself um
so if you play closer to your teammates
and closer to cover it just in it just
exponentially increases your chances of
surviving um and just being able to get
more kills so i don't know i i think
people talk about movement a lot they
say like you know there's the movement
skill gap and i i don't know personally
i consider positioning to be a part of
the movement skill gap but i feel like
people associate movement with like oh
the hunter jumps you know in the air or
you know you slide a lot but i don't
know to me um a big part of movement is
where you choose to position yourself
relative to cover teammates and the
spawn
that makes sense
um so i would say when it comes to
positioning
how much is
would you compare say like map knowledge
like okay this would be interesting rank
the importance of like these things
okay understanding map lanes
like understanding like map knowledge
teammates
and radar knowledge
where's your importance on those three
i i guess it depends on the game mode um
because i don't know i i think radar has
probably got to be the top one just
because the radar is so powerful in this
game um teammates is a close second map
knowledge probably lasts um
i i think like it you could put me on
the brand new pvp map and i know nothing
about it and i'd probably still play
fine um so i i mean i think having a
knowledge of like um like basic like how
cover works in in the map and like
knowing what a common lane is in the map
i guess that stuff's important but um
not anywhere as close to as important as
teammates and radar in my opinion you
say that shadow but who knows you you
may just
uh
have recency bias because you don't know
what it's like to have a new crucible
map you know
that's a good point
you've been living so long that you you
don't even remember what it was like
where that was an obstacle to have to
remember a new map yeah so it's it's
true i i do remember playing the d maps
but i don't know i i feel like you
weren't even legally an adult the last
time
yeah
okay okay okay even even with that i
mean i feel like after a few games i get
like a basic knowledge of how the map
works um and then beyond that there's
just like small optimizations of like oh
this is a good this is good cover or oh
this cover sucks because you know i can
just get surrounded or something but
i mean beyond that i feel like map
knowledge is fairly fundamental
you know all right so that's that's the
tip look at your radar everybody it's
important there you go gives you a lot
of information
yes it's ridiculously powerful segment
let's help ebontis and you know i've
succeeded at establishing the segment
when i no longer have to introduce it or
force it
when you
embrace it himself yeah when you when
you learn to embrace it it's it's time
yeah
i mean okay to be clear i think the
radar is extremely important just
because it's extremely powerful but i
feel like it's also like fairly
intuitive like you just look at the
radar um i'd say that positioning is a
bit more nuanced yeah i like and your
teammates so um when when you ask the
ranking of the importance um i would put
radar above teammates but that's but
like if you think about like the
complexity and like the skill level then
i would probably put like playing
together with your teammates above that
yeah especially in
you know trials for example that's one
thing for me i've played
since freelance trial started i've
played more trials than i probably ever
have now granted it's a mixed experience
because i'll go into trials with against
three stacks which is still painful
which i hope
uh we'll get to a question here in a
second but freelance is one of those
there is a rare benefit to like going
off to flank when you are in freelance
but man when you try and stick together
and then you're like okay everybody's
together and the dude peels off to the
other side that is extremely frustrating
even on my like low level
so i can only unimagine positioning at
the high level especially if you're
going threes like yeah it's gonna make a
huge difference
yeah it's it's so interesting to me how
positioning and movement and teammate
coordination changes so much like 6v6
relative to 3v3 because like especially
towards the beginning of destiny 2 and
in destiny 1 i was much more into 66
than i was in the threes um and trials
so like i i kind of got my foundation in
crucible from 6v6 and then transitioning
to 3v3 i kind of had to learn a lot more
about coordination because when you're
just playing with blueberries it's a bit
different you just kind of have to you
know
generally be near them so that they can
support you and you can support them i
mean it's it's much more basic than
coming up with like a coordinated 3v3
strategy
yeah i mean i wanted to um
ask you specifically that we don't get
hunters on a lot
so what i wanted to ask you specifically
was kind of like two things one
with the recent twab with a lot of the
aerial kind of
say nerfing but you're gonna have to
spec out into it right
if you want to play an aerial style and
accuracy and and everything that comes
with it you know you have to spec so one
as a hunter how is that affect your game
and then two
have a good friend of mine who's
very high in my clan he's a hunter maine
and man this is gonna call out my name
you can't be the child the senate is the
citizen
um yeah sinister he complains a lot
about and he this is the source of his
frustration that you know bungie
always finds a way to take the fun out
away from the hunters especially in pvp
that you know that they're quick to nerf
the hunters and the titan is it's kind
of and the warlocks are kind of lesser
they
if they have an exploit running in pvp
like it kind of glass a little longer
this he he firmly believes he feels like
bungie hates hunting i'm sure examples
of all of those right they're examples
of every class being nerfed like
warlocks of stasis were done in like
five days i mean that melee was shot to
hell but i mean you've got titans things
that laura lee was killed and i think
three seconds but then one night mask
lived for a while so you've got examples
of all of them
so funny i just want to i want to speak
for the hunter community here again he's
not here to speak for himself so i have
to be his spokesman so as a fellow
hunter one airborne stuff you're
affecting affecting your gameplay what's
your thoughts and then two
do you think
bungie's a little hard on your class
okay number one airborne um i it really
depends on my loadout sometimes like if
i use like a pulse rifle and a sniper
i'm not jumping very much um if i use a
hand cannon and a sniper i'm probably
gonna be jumping a lot more those are
probably my top two loadouts that i use
so if i'm going to be using a hand
cannon i might spec a bit more into
in-air stuff um if i'm just using a
pulse rifle then probably not as much um
i am not i am a hunter but i am a hunter
maine i almost exclusively play hunter
but i'm not the typical hunter that
flies like headfirst at mach 10 24 7. um
so
i i do have a bit more of a back of the
map sniper play style um so have you
seen it i won't say that i won't be i i
don't think that the in our thing is
gonna affect me too much overall um but
i am really interested to try out some
builds with it um and then number two
does bungie hate hunters i i think i
mentioned this in my uh the ted stage of
the hunter that
one of the stages they think that bungie
hates the hunters and i really do not
think that is the case whatsoever um
i i think that all the classes think
that like i especially on twitter like i
feel like every day i see a tweet of
someone thinking that bungie hates their
class but
i really i really do not think that's
the case at all okay okay now i i had to
go straight to the source i mean this is
some of the the conversations i hear
from fellow hunters and they just you
know they always come to me like cog you
know to admit it we have something
that's you know advantageous shadow dive
or you know whatever it's like shattered
that i've got to live shattered
13 months dude like
it's like that's one of the few times
right that they get a chance to rock out
where you know they say the other class
whether titan warlock you know we
running around with sandhill supernova
and extra long and tight running around
with what i was gonna say yeah
odysseus said stompy's has been good to
go for about five years so
that's
that's what i actually wanted to ask you
about is everybody felt like you know
every hunter got you know shot in the
kneecaps when stompies are getting this
inner accuracy penalty
do and i wanted to ask you because you
had things like offian aspects which are
really good for neutral game for
warlocks which are very popular that
actually got like a plus 10 as opposed
to a minus
like it was the one exotic what
okay you pocket stat watch it continue
start watching my warlocks look at that
yeah i know warlocks that's why
everybody thought of fittings were gonna
get hit too but they weren't and that's
one thing i was curious
do you feel with regard do you feel like
stompy's
got
very targeted for a reason and do you
think what was done to them was fair or
unfair i'm curious
i think
um okay so i got to preface this all
with i don't use stompies very much i'm
a dragon shadow maine
and with that in mind i think that
zombies were targeted just because
they've been the go-to exotic literally
since they came out um i mean with a
small exception for like warm husk or i
don't know some other random metas like
renewal grasp i guess
um but
but yeah i think i think it makes sense
that they were targeted and i think it's
relatively fair the changes that were
given i think i'm reserving more
judgment until we get to test it out um
but i think i think there was a bit of
an overreaction from stomp stompy mains
so
um
because the thing is is that even with
that inner accuracy penalty even if you
have a zero in our accuracy stat or your
effectiveness i guess is the term we
should be using but um your accuracy
will still be better than it is right
now with icarus right um it's just that
it's the aim assist so
if you if you see someone complaining
like oh they they butchered my stompies
it's like they showed you're true
yeah i was like i didn't put it all
together and then i gathered enough
information from like more of like
looking at the community and it was the
idea that all of a sudden
if you're accurate in the air you're
still gonna you're gonna almost be there
they took away the accuracy penalty in
the air they just took away the aim
assist so if you are a good shot in the
air theoretically you almost could be
better if you need the aim assist help
in the air you're about to get called
out really really badly and i think
that's actually people are just gonna be
like oh it's terrible it's like no you
apparently have to work on yourself and
i thought i'm just waiting for the
realization to start next season it's
going to be really good the funniest
thing is that accuracy actually went up
so if you are pinpoint accurate in the
air you will literally have gotten a
buff
as opposed to what it is right now so
which which skill
yeah yeah it was combined with the skill
level game assistant bullet magnetism
and curving and all that yeah it's like
you're not going to get the help in the
air so if you want to be you want to do
that type of stuff a little four on the
floor type thing but
no
that's one of those for i mean warlocks
you guys over there you need
one exotic and you're just gonna be
wings of sacred dawn you're just gonna
be hell hellscape like hanging out in
the air if you guys go
solar floating and all that stuff just i
love it terrified if i don't need the
shadow's sniping abilities on a floating
warlock when he's better more accurate
and now is almost more aim assist in the
air that's terrifying
i love it i mean i just like the there's
a part of me that loves the specking
into aspect and having to now give value
to an exotic like that because first of
all as a warlock being that is a
beautiful exotic it's the number i'll
give you it's it's up there for look not
the best yeah not best as a recent
release but yeah uh phoenix protocol
right now
ornamental
birdman with the with the feathers oh i
got like my chinchilla all right oh i
love that one but anyway
but yeah that sacred dawn was when d2
launched i was like man that's majestic
looking but yeah it's gonna be cool to
kind of but i'm glad uh shout out to you
shadow for uh kind of answering as far
as the play style and and and how they
uh attacked the whole airborne stuff and
leaning into it so i see where you're
coming from see where you're coming from
the other one i wanted to ask you about
is flinch especially as a sniper because
this is one do you see yourself building
into this
more because resilience per se for a
hunter is probably the last stat that
you normally care about
up to a certain level of being shot so
is this is this going to cause you to
like actually change anything like maybe
look for some alternate builds or like
armor spec loadouts type thing or is it
anything that you're not as concerned
about
so i think i am gonna like care about
flinch in terms of the perks uh but in
terms of resilience not that much um
because i mean the difference between
like tier two which is like what i have
right now and tier ten is eight percent
yeah i saw your video isn't that much
um so i mean i think i'm gonna care a
little bit more than i do now about
resilience but i still don't think it's
gonna become like a a go-to stat for
hunters um titans i mean sure 100 right
i mean you get the barricades back and
those can be really powerful um and then
the flinch on top of that sure why not i
mean titans can totally go for it for
pvp but for my playstyle and probably
for many hunters resilience is not going
to be a tier 10 type of investment that
people want to make are you going to go
like
unflinching double mods you probably
already have half of this stuff in here
right is there is there a lot that you
think you're going to need to change i
guess to
be more you know
less funchable type thing is there
anything you need to build into that
more that you haven't done yet
um i guess stability
um
since that's going to be changing the
flinch with certain weapons
it's going to have to be something i
experiment with but stability um is
going to become more important than ever
and right now i think it is actually a
fairly underrated stat on weapons
because people are like oh yeah i play
mouse and keyboard i don't care about
spelling but
it matters a lot and especially with the
fledge changes it's going to matter even
more yes um so i think
my my prioritization of stability might
increase a bit and then i already use
unflinching mods but um that'll just
become another part of my builds
speaking of which i wanted to ask you
about um
i love talking to pvp
oh
i gotta get you guys in here every so
often and then these two just love to go
nuts love it like i wanted to ask you
about weapon archetypes coming into next
season and like what are the
what are the weapons or loadouts that
you're kind of most excited to test out
that maybe you stashed in the vault or
just some exotics or anything that
you're looking forward to going into the
crucible
based on what you know was about to
happen to a lot of different archetypes
i'm really interested in snipers i mean
i'm manned snipers but this is the
largest sniper change we've probably
ever seen in destiny 2 so i'm really
interested to see how that pans out in
regards to the flinch in regards to the
handling in regards to the aimed on
sights and snapshot changes um
so i'm really interested to try those
out i made a sniper to your list about a
year ago and i'm probably going to
remake that one pretty soon
with all of the new snipers that have
come out since then and also with all
the new changes so i'm really i'm really
excited to try that out i think
i don't know i think generally speaking
it won't change that much like a lot of
the good snipers that are good right now
will still be good um but i'm i'm still
really interested to try out some of the
ones that i haven't tried in a while and
work with all the new systems that are
coming out with regards to that
um smg's i'm also really excited about i
think those with the changes to the zoom
in the range this one be really good
oh i don't know i i don't know we'll
we'll have to see i i think i i try to
like do a lot of testing when the new
stuff comes out and find what i like but
um 900 750 600 where you actually which
one you gonna go to first
i i don't know i like 900s um i feel
like i feel like they really do what
smgs are meant to do which is like they
melt really good in close range and
especially if you get kill cliff going
they're just fantastic
i feel like stuff like shayra's is
kind of more like an auto rifle in a way
that like it has more range but it i
don't know i like i like the 900s for
their ability in really close range
that's what's for fun well if i don't if
it was a nine or a six i'm but
i'm forgetting that i'd have to look i
feel like it's in between give me a sec
yeah quickly so do you like uh speaking
of 900's do you like the new it's a yeah
it's a 900 yeah it's at nine i felt i
was like oh funny um do you like the
raid
machine gun or smg submission do you
like it or not yeah i think i think it's
pretty good right now and i think it's
only going to become better with the new
changes so i'm interested to try it out
again um i haven't i don't have one on
my account so i haven't given it too
much play time i've tried it on other's
accounts but
yeah i don't i don't have a super firm
opinion on it i think right now it's not
that great just because of the way that
the zoom works but i think it's going to
become much more viable next season
nice
welcome back
i don't know down here don't know what i
missed no we're literally just picking
his brain on pvp for because all the
sandbox stuff in the last couple months
asking about airborne accuracy
yeah like so it's like is there any pvp
sandbox questions because we got you
know crucible brain in here and
crucible fan yourself i figure you've
got some questions of
curiosities of what's coming
we uh roasted stompy hunters we did that
yeah
yeah no i'm sad i missed that i think
that's my main piece of feedback um what
do you hope that they accomplish with
solar assuming that their rumors are
true about solar being next season
um i i hope that they keep like the main
things that make it uh
attractive right now
um and then also just bump up the
customization i think with the with all
of the 3.0 changes the biggest part for
me is the customization with the
fragments and the aspects um kind of
reminiscent of destiny one system
whether you had those huge things that
you could all select you know um i felt
like we've we've been really like boxed
into corners recently in destiny 2 with
the the trees like you had to select one
and then you don't get to customize
anything it's like nobody's gonna like
customize their jump like i mean i feel
like everyone in pvp uses strafe jump
anyway so um like i i love the
customization options that are coming
and then i just i like the
um
i like when they do changes that are
impactful but not like broken i think uh
i think void 3.0 was a little bit
overdone um so i hope the changes for
solar and arc or whatever comes next is
uh they're interesting and they add
customization but they don't make it op
uh and specifically for solar i hope
that burns aren't ridiculously op
because
what i've noticed what i've noticed a
pattern in pvp is that people despise
any time where they
can see that they're gonna die and they
can't do anything about think about it
yeah
people hated it yeah because they got
frozen and they're like well [ __ ]
there's nothing i could do and so i feel
like there could be a similar effect
with a burn if it's like you get hit by
a burn and you're gonna live for like
three seconds but then you're gonna die
i feel like people would totally hate
that so i hope there's not a thing where
it's like you die to a burn every life
that would be awful so well yeah i think
there's more counters to damage over
time now uh like i've seen i was using
um
uh le monarch uh last night in uh iron
banner and uh
because you're one of those guys
yeah well actually it's because i got
the catalyst and i had to complete the
catalyst so it's like all right might as
well do it while i'm grinding iron
banner um but yeah i i saw like warlock
uh warlock using the rift to survive it
even saw some titans throwing down their
barricade to get the overshield to help
burn it off and hunters have
probably the fewest options but they've
got that helmet that returns them when
they dodge and stuff so
there's a few options but i i wonder if
maybe
you know part of the the solar
uh kind of framework has been that heal
is a thing so maybe maybe
solar has its own counter to kind of
damage over time i think that'd be
interesting but also to your point about
void being overpowered i 100 agree it
basically broke crucible for like a
month but also i wonder if the reason it
felt overpowered is because the other
light subclasses were not a 3.0 version
and so maybe
with solar and void it'll be less of a
thing nobody's going to be using our
ark's going to be poor is going to be
crying in the closet for like three
months man yeah yeah
see that's that's the one that has me
very curious because me too
for me personally as a titan especially
what you can do with barricades now
as it's my class ability so far it's
just been a wall well now the wall can
give me an overshield and i'm going
can is are they gonna do anything else
cool with barricades for solar and arc
and i honestly wonder if they will do
anything or if it's just gonna be the
boring barricade and maybe it's other
stuff the customization is cool and all
but it's like making the class ability a
little bit better then we've got
volatile we've got those types of things
you know our grenades like is there
gonna be an aspect where your grenade
adds burn damage so now if you get hit
by any solar grenade here comes that
tick tick tick
on everything but then on the other side
like you know if you
get you know as you guys have said if
you get certain kills maybe there's a
healing aspect as well to counter it as
i'm
i'm very curious because void
while most of everything stayed
i think there were a couple things that
were lost in transition
um
i would say generally like everything
generally about void most overall is
better that we have flexibility of and i
think everything felt a lot stronger and
i'm hoping we get that type of feeling
out of solar as well for one to counter
void
so we actually have an alternate light
subclass that kind of gets there um but
also just to really make those
subclasses kind of stand on their own
the one that i'm most curious about as a
hunter is if they can make the big
sledge hammer for fire
matter at all again because
it's just the one titans and titans i
don't know what i said yeah yeah
hunter uh yeah the big sledge hammer for
titans if they can make that yeah
burning moth if they can make that good
i will be very surprised if nothing else
i'm going to have a little throwing
hammer to go with my big throwing
hammers when i customize so that i'm
looking forward to but
my theory is the
titan barricade will will deploy like a
a forward wave of fire you know like the
great i'd be down for that i'd be down
for that i bet you would
probably something like that yeah i feel
like the class abilities will do
something i feel like that's been a
pattern like with with void uh we had we
like got a new hunter dodge we got the
titan barricade um and then we've also
like with stasis like the warlock uh
rift freeze thing i feel like it's
that's just like a pattern like it's
bound to happen in some way that it
affects the class ability
what would you like to see for the
warlock and the hunter what would you
like to see solar do to your class item
and arc if you have ideas there too
i don't know i don't really have
anything specific in mind i feel like
that's you kind of have to
design like an intrinsic bombardier like
leave a little
you know leave a little sun spot on the
ground for you
that sounds so busted
please don't do that but
like that just
i mean i will definitely say warlocks by
the way
the fact that you've got an exotic that
turns any weapon into an overload
killing weapon still lurks me that
you're the only one that has like a
champion weapon and i'm just like it's a
great i love it it's awesome yeah that's
not fair that's just not fair you have a
[ __ ] gun reloading you guys have stuff
that synergize with you know weapons i
love that it's like the champion killer
we all did we all needed some of those
but you know honestly if it was
anti-barrier it'd be perfect
i was like antibiotics covered by
arbalest honestly right now that thing's
too strong
but they're about to give him a nerf but
yeah i was just like oh man if it was
anti-buried i thought rift there oh
sign me up for every night for grand
master let's go
now but it is not all jokes it is
powerful that is that is extremely i've
got is something filament i forgot
succulents
love it i was gonna ask real quick um i
know
like what do you i know you can't think
of you were saying shadow like what you
what they could do but like what do you
feel if solar's next from a hunter's
standpoint
what do you feel is kind of a weakness
that needs to be improved
uh blade barrage super sucks
really bad
that needs to get fixed um but i i think
uh like with solar 3.0 just generally i
i think it should like embrace the
powers of each subclass and like the
vibe that each one has like gunslinger
empowers your guns like you know if they
if they make the neutral game of the
gunslinger like really
really allow you to build into making
your weapons better i feel like people
would love that
um
so yeah i think just kind of embracing
the power fantasy of each one while
adding more customization just generally
speaking that that would be a w um and
i i think the trend we've fallen into
with stasis and void is so far is like
it comes out really hot and yeah
like the abilities kind of dominate for
a bit so i'm really hoping with solar
and arc that it's it's more in line with
what we had with like the 30th
anniversary where weapons are the focus
and abilities do not dominate the entire
crucible so i appreciate you seeing
optimism but i wouldn't like put money
on red if you were doing anything like
that because
the way it's been we got to hype up the
new subclass and then we got to reel it
back in
yeah i mean i think i think it's fine to
ship them a tiny bit hot i think it's
fine to ship them good i mean you need
to ship them good otherwise you know
it's just boring and nobody uses it you
don't want to ship something that sucks
um but i i think
they could you know be less op than
stasis and void were initially and that
would be the sweet spot
i was going to say outside of my dodging
sunspot terrifying
thought process
is there anything you guys think i was
like please if they do that it's already
over
is there anything you guys think they
could try and buff and almost make too
strong is there anything in solar that
you're like
you're good right here please don't do
you think there's anything that's kind
of on the brink of if they give it a
buff or it gets like a couple aspects or
something
it could go too far that you could
almost see now
i'm worried about heal
a little bit yeah just for psg because
i wonder i wonder if it makes the
recovery stat completely obsolete if you
can just sh you know i i gave my titan
wall pitch which i know there's an
exotic for it already but um if if like
deploying your titan barricade uh
instantly started healing you then you
know
most of the time you get into an
encounter do you really need that's just
the warlock rift
yeah it's a warlock rift already i don't
know what they would do for warlocks but
i'm a little worried about the
how heal plays into things um
i don't know i guess i see but that's
one thing i'm more it's kind of the same
worry i had about overshields so yeah i
think you have a good point i mean
anything that incentivizes in pvp
anything that incentivizes a player to
just sit there and do nothing sucks um
yeah so if it's like oh i'm sitting here
and i'm healing and you can't kill me
you know like i feel like barricades and
risks they're cool and all but they also
really slow down the pace of the game
which kind of sucks um so i think that
if
if any of those become op that would be
very bad
yeah what if they make an exotic for the
new season
that's kind of like perpetual motion but
for healing so the farther and longer
you run then you get healing shotgunners
would be
like we shotgunners
firing you from the sandbox team
immediately
think of all the worst things that we
know won't happen that way when this
stuff doesn't happen we're happy that's
all see i'm making us like happy with
these things they tend to listen to you
you're not gonna listen to me on this
stuff you crazy i would break this kevin
giannis is over there just like really
dude what are you doing to me like he
would just be really sad
you know that would just i'm just i
don't know i'm solo 3.0 i'll
soar is my subclass for titan
generally but anytime right now i go off
a void it feels kind of painful because
i know i'm missing so much potential so
i'm hoping solar feels as potent at
least as void point avoid 3.0 does right
now because
i just want to have a little more
flexibility arc just gets to sit in the
corner they're the sad kid in the corner
with the dunce cap on for three more
months and that's fine but at least
solar should be fun it's my hope
no doubt no doubt
well
uh guardian games week two we are into
that actually
didn't know how much how much has
everybody on the podcast been playing
guardian games i am curious how much did
you guys get into competitive scoring
anything none
none
yeah basically nothing travis is taking
me to give him an evidence
no no
they don't have it i tried it i tried it
very briefly and then quickly was like
yeah i don't want to do this yeah and
then then on top of that the title was
broken initially with the drop rate so
that kind of de-incentivized me a little
bit now i know it fixed i got to get
back in but yeah it just didn't it had a
mojo for me as well you know and i
already had you know air apparent so it
was just kind of like yeah what was my
motivations really
so yeah not so much what about you
shadow
i i've never really been into any of the
seasonal events i i feel like i've just
never been that motivated to actually do
them especially when they get repetitive
um i feel like guardian games
not even team doubles
come on our one okay i haven't played
i haven't played those um but yeah i
mean especially when things get
repetitive i think they did a pretty
good job with making guardian games not
that repetitive this year but i still
haven't really gotten into it so
e uh i've been playing a decent amount
just uh i've been trying to farm for the
title basically because i know there's a
couple rules i did get a stats for all
one for all with some pretty good range
i think i got like a four out of five
for that one video excellent i'll be
looking out for that role and then for
pvp there's a couple i got one that's
close still not quite there for my pvp
roles it just
it feels better than
i think it should just by looking at
like numbers and stats and things so i
think depending on what they do to smg's
that it's actually got some potential
and just something about that one
for me actually feels pretty good but no
the strike scoring has actually been
nice to have um
going for the medals now i will say with
regards to strike scoring that
i don't
so for one the
shoot shoot the wall kill yourself for
20 minutes and go get the 700 000 points
they have done something about that
which is good so if you're going for a
legitimate score runs they have made an
adjustment there which is a good thing
because i was honestly wasn't sure what
they were going to do typically i
figured
okay people broke the system we got the
top ten percent that was figured out
i honestly thought they were just going
to give everybody the emblem give
everybody or something and actually just
like they know what like the highest
probable ranges are going to be and then
they have actually kind of adjusted the
the outliers out of that range so it's
been um so if you did have top ten
percent and you weren't you know
lfg for one million points or whatever
and shooting a wall for 20 minutes and
then finally going in it actually is
they did adjust that one i just wanted
to give them props for adjusting it in
the right way because i think in the
past they would have gone hey here's
your free emblems things got screwed up
it's too much work to go back in and
adjust the systems or whatever and the
fact that actually
just were able to change the score
threshold make it retroactive for last
week i think they actually handled it
pretty well and i kind of wanted to
shout them out for that because a lot of
ways it could have been easier and just
like never mind no big deal here's your
emblem everybody they actually kind of
left it in there so if you did make the
effort last week theoretically you still
should probably be there
and then i've been working on the strike
scoring this week and it's just it's
interesting to see it but the only thing
i have to say is like when you're gonna
say strike scoring i understand like
power sprees cool uh super kills those
are fun you know energy like certain
things to stay alive and 30 kills
without dying those are cool sprees to
get finishers and then on champions i
get those
taunting them before you finish them
basically it's one it's the mo it's one
of the most important metals that you do
because every major
anything with an orange bar or a
champion you need to emote before you
finish
because you get a bonus of points and i
don't love that that's in there because
that's just frustrating and playstyle
it's like let me dance on you and then
let me actually finish you and i don't
because that doesn't
it's this weird thing that i've noticed
this season between the raid challenges
being play slower and keep things alive
that you should want to kill and then
this is the same thing here's the
situation where normal combat you'd be
like hey let me run through let me
finish him i can hit him real quick no i
got to get to a point where i can stop
do a little dance and then i'm actually
going to go dance on him and then finish
i think that
i think that needs pull out of strike
scoring i would like to see strike
scoring put in the vanguard playlist
maybe it helps in reputation maybe
there's something they can do with
strike scoring because strike scoring is
actually cool and fun is just to see the
numbers go up and actually have some way
to track it but also on the other side i
don't love the fact that they like they
want you to taunt the enemy which
basically makes it easier for those
moments where you're like well i want
all the points but then i'm possibly
gonna i just don't like that emotes are
a way to get extra points that's the
only thing everything else i'm actually
enjoying about it just take the emotes
out of there and i'm glad they fixed it
the way it was so you don't want to do
that against hive guardians
i've done it it's just it's it's a very
sketchy prospect
with those shields will take will like
kind of take you apart like a movie i
recently just saw but that if you
haven't seen it i won't say anything um
but yeah it's just enough i mean i like
the idea of strike scoring making say
like the vanguard ops playlist more fun
giving you a reason if they can do some
type of leaderboard in the game that
would actually be kind of cool gives a
reason to actually run that playlist
ever
but on the other side yeah it's just
like there are a couple tweaks that i
think i would make to it but apparently
i'm the only one who's played it so i'm
kind of talking to
talking to chat here and anybody else so
if anybody has any thoughts about this
throw those in the comments for us
because my hosts are
less helpful this week on the strike
scoring thrown under the bus thrown
under the bus for unfun activity
true
you know you know
i feel like
i'm not going to go there
leave it alone oh it was it was really
yeah i was going to talk about strikes
and you guys know my take so yes yeah
it's and again that's what i was like
strikes we know you see you're like hey
go do strikes for
20 different activities you know we
always have a reason to go do the
playlist or whatever and then all of a
sudden you're like
why
it's like i haven't had to do we get
like one new strike a year
what did we get two this time around or
something like that so it's like but
yeah strike scoring is
at least the way to give you a little
more in there and then that's got
potential they could do a little bit
more with it is all it's just the system
that's there we haven't had strike
scoring since destiny won
so i was like
it could be it's just something they
could do something with if they put a
little more into it if the foundation in
a couple tweaks gonna get some more
that's really all uh you know what i i
can't i can't keep it in i'm just gonna
say it so
i should have just gone on to the next
topic i should have i have such a i have
such a problem with with uh people
pointing to like oh well they did
scoring it's that makes it fun right
because they they added a score because
if if you told me hey travis go do your
laundry and i was like oh man i really
don't want to do laundry but then if you
were like hey but we'll score your your
laundry performance against all of your
other friends will tell you how well you
did your laundry in comparison i'd be
like okay fine but like it's still
boring i like still don't want to do
laundry this is like bungee is like is
like huck finn right now trying to
convince us that painting the fence is
fun like that's what it reminds me of
like like super hardcore it's like but
we don't like the activity like it you
didn't give us any new strikes like it's
like but do the same activity and over
again this time we've got scoring it's a
gimmick it's fun now it's a game and i'm
just like what now i don't shadow is
there anything that would actually
compel you to get involved in
strike scoring leaderboards anything or
you just like nope are you noping out of
there what are you doing
probably
noping out of there
that's a fair answer it's a pvp mindset
that's totally what i expected i just
had to ask so
all right you know from my point of view
with guardian games i feel like it's a
perfect opportunity to make a pvp mode
about guardian games because it's
literally about the classes i mean i was
fighting with each other how how is it
not a pvp thing i really did not get it
yeah
i said this two weeks ago
he gets the classes yeah to like getting
the three of the game
yeah three three three it's a totally
missed opportunity in my opinion 100
dude 100 when i first heard of guardian
games i was like oh sweet so it's got to
be like a pvp thing you know titans and
hunters and warlocks playing each other
and then it's just like nope it's just
like another event in the tower it's
like a passive aggressive cold war where
we're like
we're killing we're killing the fallen
but we're doing it like looking really
angry at the other classes
this is your face
in the face
my banner's higher than yours
it's like
so it's like we're roommates and we're
trying to get back at each other by like
you know not cleaning the dishes like
that's the level oh my god
dude it's almost like gambit it's like
which team can kill the enemies faster
it's like no i kill kill the enemies not
the you know the players
because they every map has three points
an absc and guess what three different
teams spawn in
go
like and then you know however wins
or maybe if they had strike scoring and
that you'd have something for both sides
right yeah i'm not saying it has to be
exclusively pvp i just think it has to
have some pvp component to get me really
interested into it yeah
i mean and that would be a nice balance
because some people are like hey i'm not
a huge fan of pvp and some people are
like i love pvp
if you could just do that for both like
the maps literally have three sides to
them almost all of them do except
probably like a couple
have very specific lanes but
that like some of them are so built for
that because i'm thinking what is it
midtown that's one i think would work
really well for that
um but there's certain maps that you
could that are divided up in the little
perfect triangle and just
three different sets of people join in
and you got arcs or you got warlocks
titans and hunters spawning on three
different sides and run
i just i would i think that would be
really cool hopefully they can do that
but yeah we talked about that before too
so i agree but yeah glad to know nobody
cares about strikes perfect all right
i mean i had to cover the topic because
it was there since that's what we're in
the middle of but yeah everybody's more
excited next week guardian games isn't
going to even be on the topic list next
week we're going to be talking about so
much season 17 stuff we won't even know
what to do with but we actually got some
season 17 stuff this week
and we've got the iron banner updates um
for those of you who haven't looked over
the twab
general idea is
iron banner is one of the core playlists
um they're trying to lower the barrier
of entry so the first thing is iron
banner
light level going away
what do we think about light level
requirements going away
i think it's very interesting because
they keep going back and forth like
in destiny 1 it was a thing and then
beginning of destiny 2 they're like yeah
you know we don't really want the power
level to be a factor anymore and then
you know more recently they're like you
know what actually let's put it back in
and now they're like wait no we're gonna
take it back out so i i don't i don't
know i i mean i don't really think it
has that big of an impact i think having
the power level in there does kind of
make it feel more like an end game
activity which i don't know if that's
necessarily good or bad but i don't i
don't think it's really going to be the
end of the world either way uh as
someone who's lazy and doesn't do his
pinnacles i guess it kind of benefits me
to not uh be max power level and you
know not be at a disadvantage because
i'm not max power level so that's fine i
mean i don't know i i think it's i guess
it's good for getting more casual
players involved but i don't think it's
like a huge factor also i think you're
my favorite guest because it's like just
it's like you watched all the previous
parroting shows i've said in the past
like couple weeks i literally said that
exact same thing
about how they just won't they will not
stick to their decisions they just
change their minds so quickly and i'm
very confused by it but yeah
i feel the same way i did order what
shadow said like that the first the
first thing i said when i when i read
this in the 12 was like
classic bungie going back on your
previous decision it's like it's like
and they hate each other and each season
one of the teams gets to gets to be in
control of destiny and they just undo
all the work from the previous
administration
control z
and then the other way just undo redo
undo redo frustration
they're super upset about what the other
team is doing yeah they they elect a new
team
yeah
i'm gonna do everything that the last
sandbox team did
it's kind of true yes it's interesting i
will say one thing i like is that um
what was that that's that specific
bounty that you always had to the other
yeah like get rid of that would annoy me
yeah that would annoy me i mean
you know here we are again i guess to
shadow's point
they view this as kind of opening the
floodgates to casualize the mode as far
as um
not letting the um
you know the the the advantage the level
advantage be a disadvantage to newer
players i guess i don't know how much of
a factor you know it's going to make and
i'm curious to see how how accessible
this makes it like do with with their
analytics does this
you know truly make players really you
know come into the game but i think it's
gonna be more of a combination of what's
going on but yeah i was actually i was
surprised i'll be honest what i saw i
was like oh okay you're doing this
interesting but what about you
uh i mean for me i think it's just a
general it's probably where they should
leave it
because pvp should be about the player's
skill
about your weapons your loadouts your
build of your character
not the arbitrary power level number
that we have now granted the power level
number going up for pve stuff i get
that's that's a thing but for pvp as it
is meant to be about the player versus
the player
combat not so much you're leveling up
it's like you know it's the imaginary
sandbox it's not the imaginary sandbox
but i'm 1560 and you're 1550. that
shouldn't matter like it should be about
the
player skill the abilities can you hit
your shots not if i shoulder chart it
used to like the things that annoyed me
the most as a titan of course but
if i could shoulder charge somebody but
when i was slightly under leveled they'd
have that smidge of health and i'm like
when it's a one-shot ability that should
always be that way so the fact that it
wasn't was one of those and same thing
it might take one more shot you do a
little less damage
that type of stuff if momentum control
is going to be a different set like
momentum control is cool different
sandbox weapons kill really fast it's
kind of a different you know time to
kill very different
but if iron banner is just going to be
like control it shouldn't be controlled
but there's this like slight variation
in people like just even it out and i'm
i think it's i think that one they
should leave again they have it in uh
trials just because they want that to be
the end game
do you guys think light level should
matter in trials or do you think that
one should still be do you think that
one should be normalized as well
um i i think it shouldn't
philosophically uh it doesn't really
make sense to have the scaling uh in and
also i'm kind of like shadow and that i
don't do my pinnacles i just play
crucible usually and so uh it definitely
benefits me in making an argument for
myself
but i also
think that if you want to do something
there's
there's very few other places in destiny
where your power level matters even in
pve
so if you want it if you want it to be
an endgame activity that's restrictive
then just make the power level
requirement high you know what i mean
like they do with grand master nightfall
if you were like oh you got to be
this level of power level to enter the
activity then that would gate it i think
the reason they don't do that is because
trials already let's face it has a
playlist population problem and they
probably aren't trying to add some
additional barriers but i also don't
know why they do it to grandmaster
nightfall like what's the what's the
reasoning behind yeah i mean if it's
capped anyway why why do you have like a
super high power level requirement to
get into it so um yeah i don't i don't
think they should add it i and i say
that as a guy who kind of likes it i
kind of like it when like i was playing
iron banner and i'm not max power and i
was fighting guys that were like 20 30
power above me
yeah i'm kind of getting my ass handed
to me this is kind of nice uh you know
some of these encounters don't i feel
like i'm not doing that much damage but
um you know if you're trying to design a
competitive multiplayer game it doesn't
really make that much sense to to have
you know the power level really come
into play so
shadow what about you light levels
in trials i guess i'm gonna make kind of
a argument against myself because like i
said i don't do my pinnacles and i'm
lazy but
um i actually think it's fine to have
the power level enabled in trials as an
endgame activity it gives you a reason
to do uh your pinnacles and your
powerfuls and actually level up your
character and get ready for trials i
feel like it kind of especially because
trials isn't a thing at the very
beginning of the season or expansion i
guess it's like it's like a reason to
like
grind and get ready and there's like an
anticipation factor i think to it but
also like it doesn't make that big of a
difference like if i'm a little bit
under leveled i can still win in trials
like my skill is still the thing that
matters um it's just like a slight like
a slight factor that makes it slightly
more difficult if you haven't reached
max level so i i don't i think it's i
think it's fine the way it is because
it's not a massive factor if you're
slightly under leveled but if you want
to really min max and get to the maximum
power level and have all all your mods
and the perfect rolls on all your
weapons then you can do that and it will
make you better but if someone is super
skilled and they're 10 power levels
under they're still going to win
there that's a good take on it and
that's kind of one of those things that
is for
general engagement like if you're a pvp
player it's still going to cause that
player to engage in much more of the
game each season to be able to get up to
level so it's a
it's a you know it's a seasonal
engagement thing as opposed to you could
be 13 50 for the next year and still go
complete and kick ass in trials like
they need i think that's a large reason
why it's there in the first place
because like if you're a pvp player like
you do like the basic campaign to unlock
the exotic or something like that and
then you're done like
like what's the reason to do the
powerfuls of the pinnacles so i guess it
kind of it gives people a reason to play
more of the game right
bungie likes you know ever it's it's
just a win for everyone basically other
than the people who don't like grinding
but yeah i mean it gets you it gives you
a reason to actually go do those things
even if you're more a pvp player so i
think that's fine i mean
all right now i got to get
no what were you going to ask no i was
going to say yeah i agree with you i
think that's the mindset they have
behind it is because
they want the grind they want the the
the pv pvp player just to aspire to
continue to plan and make sure the light
level
to reward the person who wants to commit
to the light level right but at the same
time i do feel it even though i like it
personally i do feel it goes against
their own philosophy of trying to make
the mold more inclusive because at the
end of the day it's like you know
there's going to be a certain amount of
people that get to that pinnacle you
know and
at the same time they'll have that
advantage but
they if they have competing philosophies
issues right now and i think that's
what's going on and that's why i keep
going back and forth whether it be a
regime change like travis mentioned or
you know whatever it is there's
definitely
philosophy debates in that building and
you know it it's it shows the
inconsistency where we see sandbox
updates like this but personally i like
it but i understand i understand you
guys yeah it's weird because
if the light level did matter but the
highest you could go was say like the
powerful cap
for an entire year and then the
expansions were more content not the
little 10 level bump then theoretically
yeah you'd have to hit that 1550 but
then it's always then you get to that
little seasonal bump every time and it's
always that little nuance of difference
where if somebody you know it's that 10
levels and the people grind the
pinnacles in early trials when the
population is bigger are gonna have a
bit a smidge of an advantage not much as
you guys have said but a smidge would be
there um
and again it's always that weird thing
is even the 10 level bump
worth it with the pinnacles at that as
you said you actually said it well
because yeah there's some people who
probably don't want the level changes
that much some people have probably
questions if the level number should be
in the game at all um then there's
people because we've actually talked
about like is power level even a
worthwhile number in the first place
they've done the 50 levels they've done
the 10 levels then you have the powerful
and then the the pinnacle every season
it's all the weird little nuances of
level right now that make some of these
things strange because then when you
start a new season you're like okay i
was at the highest well now i got to do
it again well maybe i'm crazy at work
for two months and then let me pick it
up well now i'm at a disadvantage even
if it is 10 levels i feel like i'm just
a little bit under and as you said the
idea of trials would be we want as many
people playing this as possible
so it is kind of you know butting
hands-on ideas but i did have a question
for shadow
because
i wanted to get your take
do you think freelance should be
permanent in trials
it's a it's a really good question i
don't know it's it's there's a lot of
pros and cons um i think with all of the
splittings of population it kind of is a
bad thing um because you know when you
have the flawless pool and then you have
the different consoles and then you have
pc and then you have freelance as well
like it really it can split the
population that's never a good thing um
but people do love freelance myself
included um and it's really cool to just
be able to go into trials and you know
try to go flawless by yourself or i mean
even if you're not going flawless it's
still fun to be able to queue without
organizing your friends into a group and
you know having this whole ordeal um so
i don't know i think i think overall
freelance is a good thing um there's
just some challenges that it has when it
comes to splitting the population
does anybody did you major in like
politics what'd you do because i swear
every answer i asked you is like
so pc middle of the road could be half
of this like you are really good at
dancing a lot of both sides of this i
was just kind of curious it cracks me up
because i look like a computer science
major he's a moderate man after my
i don't know i think i think with some
issues there are extremes but i i think
i don't know a lot of a lot of the ones
that we've mentioned so far i don't have
a super strong heart
no it's just it's cracking me up because
there's a couple questions you'd be like
well this or that it's like i was
curious if you would give both audiences
arguments i'm like i usually do that
i like being able to see both sides yeah
i like being able to see both sides
because i i really i don't think that
there are very many issues especially in
when it comes to balancing games where
there's one opinion that's correct and
the other one's wrong so i think
appreciating both sides is important
so
okay question
you have the ability to make the trials
matchmaking system however you want solo
freelance flawless not flawless pool
what do you build that you think is the
best for everyone what is your
preferential in-game for the trials
playlist in the world of matchmaking
um i think i probably
steal an idea that i've seen thrown
around a few places which would be um
connection and card base which what
which is what it is right now but then
on sunday you activate the freelance and
there's no such thing as the flawless
pool
interesting
so no skill based at all
no skill base at all that's currently
the way it is
um
to your status quo what it says i'm
curious
no he basically just said like
take like a normal trials weekend as is
and then on sunday
add the flawless node in the corner
or add the freelance freelance
yeah all sort of freelance later and i
just try to understand the mindset
behind the freelance later
um so right now the the problem is that
people think like the flawless pool is
like it activates on sunday right and
people are like oh so then i'll just go
and play on sunday but instead of having
the uh the flawless pool you can just
add freelance and that makes it a lot
more accessible
so the freelance players
only get to play
i mean well i mean i guess but you could
also just make a team or solo queue
right i mean you can always sell look
you so um freelance is just making it
more accessible and easy for a solo
player to go flawless because i also
okay another thing that i would do
is potentially um weight the
matching solos versus solos and teams
versus teams because right now there's a
problem where if you're a three stack
you're probably gonna match a lot of
solos um and then you just run them over
because you have coordination i mean
like you could a worse team will always
beat a better team if they have comps
than the other teams randoms so like
communication is huge so i i think that
if they they could they could even
potentially do away
they could they could potentially even
do away with freelance altogether if
they just heavily prioritized matching
solo queues with solo queues that's what
i would love yeah that's the biggest
thing for me
it just really screws up the whole the
whole experience when you're a solo
player and you get bashed against a team
and it's like well you know even if
we're cracked we're probably gonna lose
just because of communication so
that's probably my biggest thing and
that's kind of
i guess that's what i was leading to
mostly because me as a solo player
because i don't typically have you know
people that want to play trials or it's
just i you know pop on and i want to
play a few trials matches just like kind
of out of nowhere and it's a way to play
that but it's the idea of as soon as i
pull up the roster i'm like oh what do
we got and i see a three stack i wish i
could just quit the match i'll give
trial
you'll get a you know matchmaking
penalty or whatever it is but it's like
yeah and some people do that but if i
just want to not have that penalty just
queue up again normal without having
like a timer
that's as that's why i would say it's
like if there's not going to be skill
based matchmaking
in the factoring at all then i'm 100
with you that that weight needs to be
insanely heavy for like teams twos and
ones and solos that almost needs to be
like equal to connection as much because
yeah it's that moment where you face a
three stack and i don't i've you know
i've done enough solo queuing this
season i think i'm on my
i think i've reset my reputation twice
so i've played enough to it's like
there's enough times when you're going
in as a solo it sucks to face a three
stack it just does
every blue moon you'll pull it out like
i'm with like two cracked people and we
paired up with like the okay team but 98
of the time i'm gonna lose that match
when i see the two clan names the clan
tags that match
i'm like oh man
you know they're good friends they've
got the synergy going
yeah it's the only two people in the
back the only two people in the match
are like paired together and you're like
are they on my team are they on my team
and then all of a sudden you're like
nope nope
[Laughter]
that's yeah so if so that's why
um
i don't know if i'll bring up the whole
skill based matchmaking debate with you
even though i'm very curious um but the
weight for trials no just in general
like skill based matchmaking versus
not so much i know trials is like you
got connection and lag believe me if you
have that if you q in the morning you
got that name that you can't read that's
you know different language over there
i'm like yeah there's probably a little
bit of lag in this match that's not
great i get the lag point per se but i
was just curious your thoughts on
because it's been in like a lot of pvp
games so i don't know if you play other
pvp games if you're just mostly focused
on destiny
just the idea of skill based matchmaking
in general where do you fall on
and this could be for travis this can be
for cog because all of you guys play pvp
in different places where do you fall on
the idea of
skill based matchmaking being a factor
in literally just pvp in gaming
okay well earlier you mentioned how i
don't have a strong opinion i do have a
strong opinion
okay here we go there we go
strongly i am strongly opposed to
skill-based matchmaking in uh like
casual playlists like 66.
um i i don't think it has any place in
it like a casual playlist like 6v6 and
in trials i i think it's also the same
thing because
nobody's ever going flawless if you have
a 50 chance of winning it's it's never
gonna happen it's like a one in 100
chance or something like that you know
um so i think it does have a place in
like competitive uh like 3v3 stuff like
that because well actually it depends
what what type of competitive um i think
it belongs in competitive the way it is
if there's a ladder system that's
different but
um overall especially for 66 i do not
like skill-based matchmaking at all
trav i'll let you go out where it is
so actually
my initial reaction was oh this this
streamer elitist
fight against people who are a skill
level that was my first thought but
actually the way he framed it i kind of
agree with casual playlists you don't
really need skill-based matchmaking for
obvious reasons um also at teams of that
size it doesn't really make sense a
whole lot um
trials there's an argument for it but
also it has the card based system as
sort of a
in card
skill based system so you you could get
away with it i still have my doubts that
that system actually works but um if
you're actually matching with people who
are on the same uh win level is you
that could essentially replace the need
for a skill-based system
competitive badly needs it
badly because competitive is by
definition not competitive if you don't
have a skill-based system it's just not
it's not competitive if you're not
competing against people who are near
your skill level so you said something
about like ladder take
i don't know i picture starcraft or
something where you have like you know
bronze one two and three silver one two
and three if destiny which you know we
could all have pipe dreams that the
glory situation eventually turned into
like a ladder system every season
if that happened
do you guys feel
you know that that basically becomes
what your skill based matchmaking is
that where you end up falling into is
that where skills is okay time
more if it's a ladder skill-based
matchmaking yeah i mean if it's a ladder
and it's like you know you you win you
go up blah blah blah you know like if
you're super highly ranked you're not
going to be matching some noob so
yeah i think that's totally fine and i
also think that with the i said this
before with the with the current system
i think skill base is fine and
competitive
the argument for skill based and casual
is the lobby balancing argument which
people complain about how bad lobbies
are balanced and the reason for that is
because there is no skill based
matchmaking and it's near impossible to
actually balance a lobby if you have a
random selection of people with very
very diverse skill sets and so i think
for player experience skill based
matchmaking as does actually make sense
um i just think that depending on your
goal with the game mode it it just
depends i'm a big advocate for
skill-based matchmaking because i think
that
i want to play against people who are
close in my skill level i want matches
to be interesting and close and uh that
is not always the opinion of some people
but you have to keep in mind that for
every person that wants to be the guy
just raffle stomping there's also a team
that's getting raffle stomped and that's
not particularly good experience and i
also just think that there's a certain
level of like cowardice of like oh well
i don't want to have to be bothered to
get sweaty and to like deal with people
at my skill level and it's like all
right well then don't don't play
competitive multiplayer like go go do
strikes go do strike scoring i hear
that's less competitive
i would just like to put this out there
that i think a lot of people who are
against skill-based matching is it it's
not because they want to stomp noobs
myself included it's a lot more complex
than that but give me yeah i was like
yeah this is why because i was about to
ask because you got people that are
going to be like
i suck at pvp and i go into there and i
see shadow and all i see is a shadow
name and i see a dead screen and that's
that's my screen every time i pop up and
i get picked off i pop up and i get
picked off how how is this a fun
experience for me so
yeah i guess my my uh argument against
that shadow would be they don't say it's
to stop noobs they say that they don't
want to be in sweaty matches which is
the same thing if you don't want to be
in a match that's sweaty it means you
want to play against somebody who's a
significantly lower skill level than you
aka you want to stop noobs it's the it's
the same concept you just said in a
different way
well not really because it's for all
skill levels it's making everybody a
sweaty match you could be a 0.1 kd and
it's going to match who gets 0.1 kds
which makes it a sweaty match for you
you could be a 10kd it's going to only
match you against ted katie's which is
going to be a slight match for you and
so they don't want that they don't want
sweaty matches aka they they want to
stomp noobs i mean essentially that's
what they're getting at right they don't
want to be matched against other 10 kds
if you're a 0.1 kd and there's no skill
based matchmaking you're going to get
stomped it's you know it's the other way
around right so like i i know people who
are like not very good pvp players and
they're still against skill-based
matchmaking so what's their argument for
it i'm actually curious yeah i'm just
curious like what are they it's like
people voting against their economic
interests it doesn't mean it's a good
idea just because people are foreign
let's go
we got travis getting all split no
like hey attack the argument don't say
well some people are for it it's like
well some people are for you know
beheading people in the streets it
doesn't mean it's a good idea so give me
the actual reason not to attack you
shadow i i truly am curious because
this is and again this is why it's like
having a pvp
person on here i would ask this of a lot
of people and this is one of those
i was lucky enough to like raid for a
little while with true vanguard
um
so and actually kind of heard him phrase
one piece for me that i liked
a piece of like having some skill based
matchmaking in there but mostly relation
to like outliers
take like as you kind of said in the
casual playlist if you can eliminate the
idea that you know as fallout would say
johnny two thumbs
versus you know the
cammy cakes those two should not be in
the same lobby like if you can get rid
of like outliers of like a one versus a
ten if you can get a closer
range they're not all gonna be like
you're not all threes
but it's not like there's a one and a
ten in the same room maybe it's like you
know two to six yeah some are going to
be better some are going to be worse and
that might help with the balancing but
if you have like a 10 and a couple ones
and twos
somewhere there's going to be a huge
disparity do you feel that would be
maybe a reasonable middle ground where
it's not like casuals and you know
sweaties all the time but it's also the
idea that that one person who is god
tier probably needs to play a little
higher echelon and somebody who's that
newbie probably plays the little lower
echelon is that
is that a balance that you would be okay
with or is that still just dancing too
much with sbm for you
i i'm more open to it but i still don't
think it would necessarily be a good
system because think about it like how
many echelons are there gonna be is it
gonna be like you know you get to a
certain combat rating and then it's like
boom you're in the better tier and now
now you're getting [ __ ] on you know all
of a sudden the opponents just magically
got better you know like i feel like it
would suck to like improve as a player
and then get rewarded by your opponents
becoming better it's like well yeah
iron and now you have a chance to play
against people who are better and will
make you better by playing with them
that is like in in like in essence
exactly what you want in a competitive
system and it's what all the best
competitive games do it's what okay well
i would not consider 66 to be
competitive i'd consider it a very
casual playlist
i'm not necessarily advocating for that
i'm just saying in general if you want
matches to feel better you have to fix
the lobby problem you don't fix the
lobby problem without a ladder system or
skill based matchmaking and i think that
there's a lot of like you know
painting the argument in certain ways of
like oh well you know skill-based
matchmaking that would be so against you
but ultimately it would make matches
feel better it would make them feel more
balanced they would be sweatier
especially if your top echelon player
that's going to be tough on you but i
mean this is a tale as old as time halo
2 had skill based matchmaking and the
really good players used to spend hours
just committing suicide so that they
could lose matches and de-rank
themselves so that they could play
against worst players like that's just
that's awful
i know that's before your time but that
was like what they did back in the day
because of
their opposition to skill-based
matchmaking which is a hilarious
conundrum but ultimately that's
you know that's a problem you're going
to face if you get better and i think
the important thing maybe where we can
find middle ground shadow is that if
there is some kind of ladder based
system then you don't just get rewarded
by
playing against better players and
having even harder matches but you also
get rewarded for reaching that tier in
the latter at the end of the season you
get you get cashed out for the highest
tier you achieved
and i think that that could potentially
make it feel a little bit better when
you're improving as a player and going
up against increasingly more difficult
players because you feel at least
there's progression and that that's
that's a system that's worked in you
know rocket league and you name it we
need a competitive playlist which is the
biggest like argument for all for sure
for sure that's the thing you need a
reason
you need a reward for actually reaching
those new tiers beyond just getting
better because i think uh in this day
and age these millennials these gen zers
they really they like to they they need
something to show for getting to that
next tier of skill that just
get the participation metals in here now
okay anyway all i was trying to get to
is
i knew this was gonna be spicy anyway i
didn't actually know it was gonna be
spicy but i was honestly i knew this was
gonna be but like that's i
i was honestly curious on the take
because
um
there are people who are gonna be on
both sides of this coin you can put a
whole bunch of pvp players in there of
all skill levels and it's going to be a
debate every time because you've got
as some people like i mean i've heard
you know another podcast talk about the
idea of i want to go into a match just
with a non-optimal loadout
just to be able to try
different weapons see how they feel hey
this one okay this this can have some
potential here with this build but if i
have to
go into even control and it's going to
be my 10 out of 10 sweats fest i can't
try anything else and i've heard that
debate before and i kind of i was like
okay so i can kind of understand and
that's where i was like the outlier some
range of like you know
that might be a way to help a little bit
as you said there needs to be some a
little bit of skill in the background
like a one probably shouldn't be with a
10 but if there's like a two and an
eight sure like a ten and a four okay
like there it can be a pretty wide range
but like a one into ten for that one
that's just gonna be a bad day for him
until he gets to be a little better but
on the other side
if that level 10 player is gonna jump in
and be like hey i'm gonna try i'm a
really good sniper shadow i'm an awesome
sniper i'm gonna go and you're probably
good with everything so who knows but
it's like i'm gonna go try and run
sidearms and shotguns just to see about
being aggressive for a little while if
you do that in your usual matchmaking
group and you're not used to that play
style you're like well i have no place
to even try and get better at this and
that's one of the arguments that i've
heard about and that's where i kind of
see
that there needs to be some
connection based but it's just like kind
of that hint of where there's a little
bit of balance of both where the person
who gets crapped on doesn't want to get
crapped on every match
and if they can't have a chance to play
against people around them they feel
like they can't get better but on the
other side i do understand it's like
maybe you just want to use a different
gun but if you don't use the optimal
meta that's like the quickest time to
kill for all of these things then it's
not going to be a fun match for you so
it's like i've listened to those i was
just curious your take on it not trying
to like target you by the way because i
feel like we all went at you so i just
wanted to let you know
yeah no i i totally agree with that with
like i feel like being forced to use the
meta feels awful like if there's like
heavy skill based matchmaking like every
player at every skill level is going to
be feel they're going to feel forced to
use the meta at all times if they want
to have a chance of doing well and i
feel like that would be extremely awful
um
like you know if if i go into crucible
right now i could like you know like you
said you use a sidearm a shotgun
i wouldn't do nearly as well as i
normally do but i would at least do okay
you know like i feel like at least
having the option of using something
that's not meta is extremely important
because otherwise the crucial gets
extremely monotonous when every single
person is using the same weapon every
single game so
no i hate why would you guys say i was
just jumping real quick um my only con
would be just
to me that's the purpose of the standard
game mode that's the purpose of the
standard control the standard rumble and
to me that's where the connection blaze
stuff can live you know what i mean but
i personally feel skill based matching
sale based matchmaking for an end game
activity should be part of it
competitive and trials you know what i'm
saying like if the goal is to make this
end game the highest end game content
you don't have to get it but i would
like to play against you know the people
of similar skill to truly add value to
the mode to make it like a prestigious
thing versus standard and i feel like
standard is where you know you can bust
out you know your loadout or whatever
you want to do and i think that's
perfectly fine you know i don't
i'm with travis in this sense like i
don't i don't understand the the logic
of we're playing a casual mode but like
people are upset with the lobby balance
because if you want the lobby balance
then you're going to have to implement
skill based matchmaking so to me it's
it's an example of the community you
know kind of talking out of both sides
of their mouth you can't have it both
ways it has to be one so to me let the
casual modes have the connection based
matchmaking but trials and if you want
to consider iron banner
in game mode fine if not casual fine but
competitive needs that and i feel like
they are the creators of one of the
greatest systems
as far as the the ranking and that whole
kind of like elo kind of thing
themselves they're the creator of it
with halo so i don't see why they don't
want to kind of completely invest into
that aspect especially with competitive
and that's and then the last thing cause
y'all know i'm team reward
and if we're gonna do the competitive
you know i just want
those players rewarded you know it
doesn't everything has to be mountaintop
and recluse but i do feel there should
be those activities to incentivize me
going into that mode because it really
did it really made me get better it made
me really covet mountaintop i see an e
in there you know you know going in
there doing things you don't say that he
probably wouldn't have normally done
because there was that that carrot at
the end like man i really want that and
i think it kind of sucked when you know
i know listen i never got not not
forgotten lunas i never earned that but
i was okay with it i was just like hey i
wasn't good enough to get it and i
didn't put the time in to get it right
so i felt it when people who earned that
and blood sweat and tears and that is
okay now we're just saying that thing
that that hurts i i feel a shout out to
gaben forte so that's where i'm at with
it i understand both arguments i
understand the argument about wanting to
just you know play with a loadout and
have fun but to me it's like okay we got
standard control we got all these other
modes people could go in there and do
that rumble and all that stuff and
hopefully it could live there but it'll
be interesting to see how they how they
move forward with this thing yeah i
would i think i would probably agree
with everybody here competitive comp
whatever it's going to be called in
destiny needs a complete revamp because
the glory system right now isn't quite
there if they could do a true ladder
a true anything else in competitive
that like that whole system needs to
actually
as you said have the skill ranking to it
and that level if there could be
you know a little more casual go and
practice play a couple different modes
but having a true
like sweat sweaty mode where you can
climb up the ranks and then as you said
cog have the rewards in there whether it
might be a weapon whether it might be
skins whether it might be ornaments
whether it might be what are those
stupid things now mementos
shaders emotes emblems a whole bunch of
stuff emblems all of those things to say
i've kicked more and more ass than
anybody else in here this season like
emblems are a heart and emblems those
types of things are not as much where
they need to make are not i would say
overly difficult it seems like they can
produce those in a quicker manner those
are the type of things that i would like
to see them put into and you're like hey
if you get up to what is halos onyx if
you get up to onyx in destiny 2 or
whatever that is you get those you get
something elite that season and then
you're only going to be able to get it
that season and that's them putting a
true team on a comp playlist that's
going to have a continual investment
that they put into it and that's just a
big investment for bungie to do
last point i'll say is what i know it's
silly but you know what i respected when
i used to go to the tower and i seen
someone have redrix with that ornament
that i know
he earned that like because remember
registers was a problem bro better red
chicks to get it at first when they
first dropped
oh it's possible
yeah yeah i think they should make uh i
think they should make titles too for
different yeah sure
there's so much opportunity in this game
for cosmetics you know titles you know
emblems you just listed up like a
trillion things you can make for rewards
uh from competitive from a ladder you
know like there's there's so much
potential to put like meaningful loot
behind pvp and i think that's something
we've really been missing like i mean
look at witch queen we had so many new
weapons and how many new weapons were
there in crucible like two three two
like
yeah that hand cannon that i have
and all the chasm cause cosmetics were
ever
as well yeah there's yeah
there has to be
like if destiny's gonna continue to be a
pvp and a pve game we we need like
something in pvp that's meaningful to
like yeah i'm 100 with you on team lou
we need we need someone to like take
good rewards in crucible to make people
like actually have a reason to play it
because i mean if it's a looter shooter
game like a big motivation for playing
any activity i love it it's gonna be the
loot so i mean
you know
like some there are some pve activities
that honestly suck like they're boring
but people play them because the loot so
i mean even if people hate crucible like
if you put loot there people are still
gonna want to go for it please
i want stop guys to just digest what he
said just digest what he said
put his child
make sure i got now
all i was gonna say is
if you guys want to post on twitter if
you guys hashtag us anywhere the hashtag
of the week is teamloot i just gotta
throw that out over the channel
subscribe for good luck
my guy my god i like this every weekend
you made cognito happy earlier
actually fits in the middle with a lot
of our philosophies all of us and it's
kind of cool
anyway so with regards to iron banner
shadow just so you know the reason you
the reason you stepped in it there was
because last episode i think it was last
episode i think it was uh cog and i got
into a knock down drag out over uh
whether you should fix the loot system
or make the actual game mode fun and i
was on team game being fun i can't
believe that i have to even say that
both
and he was i'm on team both
no you're you said team loot don't talk
to me you said even if they hate
crucible they'll play it for the loot so
like that's not team game
i said they could walk and chew gum at
the same time i'm pretty sure you could
be on both teams i mean i think
we're walking with the team
[Laughter]
i'm just saying you can walk into gum at
the same time but if you had to say
which one was more important
the gum or the water
more important guys let's be honest we
don't we don't need anything
he's so cool i will be at the cereal in
this time we're not gonna believe this
again we're gonna move forward but yes
shadow you uh you unfortunately you you
you poke to the proper you poked the
bear of travis which was i loved how you
did you were like he was so good i'm so
on board and then yeah and then yeah but
that was hilarious make sure you
remember the channel yeah
yeah please
make sure
if you guys haven't followed shadow find
them on youtube find them on twitter
find them on instagram
where do you stream twitch occasionally
twitch yeah so fine
find him everywhere please make sure you
like subscribe follow go watch his video
put that playlist on like let it play
while you're sleeping support this man
he's a great great creator
thank you man absolutely
as for iron banner now we're actually
getting back to the twab
a little while later um iron banners are
gonna get a reputation rework so it's
going to be similar we got in-gram
focusing kind of like trials it feels
like but you've got a little bit more of
a tweak to the reputation and this is
one of those things where they really
want iron banner to be a thing
so you've got the reputation but you've
got ways to make your reputation gains
faster
so if you're wearing iron banner armor
or ornaments which i have to give a
massive thumbs up for that one which
that's huge
um you're gonna get your reputation
faster if you're wearing five pieces of
armor
ornaments or weapons
uh if you complete the daily iron banner
challenge it's going to tack on 100 to
your challenge for each one during the
course of iron banner so you'll earn
that reputation faster and if you're
wearing the emblem
that's ten percent more
um everything else is probably going to
be like get your engrams as you rank up
on reputations focus those in your armor
your weapons kind of similar the way it
is right now
i was curious what you guys thought
about the whole
we want you to look like you are
sponsored by saladin's iron banner to go
into iron banner i was like you have
been nascar like patched everywhere your
your car your you you look like
the the sponsor of ghosts
[Laughter]
hashtag ad on this one i was curious to
you guys thoughts do you like do you
wish the reputation was there do you
like the idea if you really lean into
the iron banner look that you can earn
more
just kind of curious if you guys have
any care or thoughts about this or
you're just going to do it because it's
what you got to do
i think it's fine with me i mean i don't
know i think it's a fast improvement
over our current system and you know
adding cool things like you know put on
your armor for extra reward or extra
reputation that's i don't know it's
personally fine with me i don't really
think it's like gonna be a massive issue
but wasn't that a thing in destiny 1
where like you'd be on a certain emblem
yeah so i i don't know i thought i
thought that was always cool you ready
to do a tv they're all writing the
banner emblem you know they're serious
about it or something you know i don't
know i think that's fine you're like the
solo player who jumps why is everybody
got the same emblem on and i'm not gonna
figure this out
yeah so yeah i like it overall
nice
yeah
uh daily challenge oh no daily
challenges it just says for the first
four days you're gonna have an iron
banner challenge if you log in on friday
you're gonna be able to work on all four
so you can go hard on the weekend if you
want to but i would honestly say the
most important thing that happened out
of this entire swab not really but for
one of ours
there's a new title coming for iron
banner and it is called let's go iron
lord
literally iron lords podcast is here in
the house
cog how you feeling sir uh are you going
to disneyland next what's happening bro
we've talked about this since this
podcast started it was a travesty
a travesty that this title did not exist
except especially for iron banner
especially a pvp focused title long
overdue
literally our podcast was based on
destiny based on rise of iron i've been
clamoring for this since i bought that
ten dollar emote with the iron lord
remember remember this one
this was ten dollars i bought that just
to show off how bungee i wanted this i
don't care what i gotta do y'all know i
don't care about titles
i don't care what i gotta do [ __ ] is
getting this title so if i
butcher you i i i harass you if i say
hey what are you doing if they want
you're going to get 100
kills he'll be out there doing it ever
it's going down when you see me in the
tower
iron lord lord [ __ ] oh it's going down i
cannot wait now question
young wolf is a title too or is a quest
uh becoming a young wolf is the new
quest not a type okay that's a quest
okay yeah sorry but the addict will have
to be iron lord as well yeah i thought
he was gonna get his own title
but now this is this long overdue and
we're taking the most serious these are
just the little things bungie right
again we like you know wearing the gear
now i will say i know we didn't get to
this yet but they did they're going to
rework a lot of other things with the
reward system and stuff like that please
please bring back the d1
armor set with the fire in the chest
like really go all in man let's take it
yeah they got to get a new set of armor
next to that next season they have to do
that let's go man but now this this
means a lot to me my my literal podcast
is founded off that destiny i wouldn't
be anything where i would be if it
wasn't for destiny in this game and iron
laws and and iron banner that's what we
did so this is this is a it's a great
deal and this is the happiest i've been
saying
if you get that iron lord title you have
to also equip the last word
uh on your
on your character for the entire season
a fully sponsored branded nascar driver
two i hope just because you have to do
it i hope that that title is a nightmare
i hope that they make you
you know run around on mars and get
those uh collectibles lower those things
you're gonna need to finish the master
val challenges while wearing the iron
banner ornaments or something
i hope one of the triumphs is that you
have to play through the
curse of osiris campaign a hundred times
and i'd want you to stream it i want you
to stream yourself playing the christmas
cyrus campaign 100 times oh they would
pay me as they they do anybody's stuff
any of that solo dungeon
no pve
yeah you're gonna need to go ahead and
do a solo flawless run of prophecy for
this one it's in there i've seen the
quest already so you're good
um also i uh i feel very strongly that
if you were an iron lord in destiny 1
you should get this title automatically
because literally i am an iron lord like
my guardian is yeah it's like canon i
have that title they used to call me
iron lord
before uh you know he got amnesia in
destiny 2 and forgot that i was his boy
um so yeah i don't know but that bums me
out a little bit it's a destiny two
title you gotta you gotta earn it fresh
it's it's no but but travis is right by
law we were made iron lords and he gave
us what is the young wolf's house or
yeah like we have the title already so
it's interesting how they gonna gonna
give it to us back
they gotta make you earn the new
cosmetic for putting the time in we know
this
yeah you know salad and he's he forgot
about the little people when he became a
brackis you know he's really wow he's
really just outgrown people shadow do
you see what i deal with every week this
is
[Laughter]
this every week
now i do have a question for you guys on
this piece of the twab because i
had a bit of a moment when i was even
reading this thing out and it was
um
saladin has changed his out to lunch be
back in 15 minutes sign or hangs his
sign due to his increased
responsibilities on kyle's war council i
love the lore reasons for this
he now runs iron banner in the tower
just twice a season
because iron banner will be more in line
with those annual events you'll never
see iron banner run during those annual
festivities for season 17 iron banner
will run these times week 2 may 31st
week 8 july 12th
that's it
on top of that we haven't got to the
game mode yet which we will here in a
second rift is coming back
the only times you are going to play
rift in season 17 are those two weeks in
iron banner
so we'll get to the details on rift if
you guys haven't seen it
here i'll just tell you what it is real
quick it's fine i'll just go through
basically if you haven't played rift
before it was in destiny 1 there's a
spark in the middle picture like a
little glowing ball you would pick it up
and you would try and go dunk it
sometimes with style if you did a
reverse dunk into your team's basket
basically um
that is
rift kind of in a small nutshell there's
a couple tweaks to it where now you're
going to be able to pick up the spark
it's going to act like basically a buff
or you're still going to be able to use
your weapons but the idea is you pick it
up in the middle there's no points for
killing so it's all about the objective
of getting your
spark or the main middle spark to the
team's basket and dunking and you got to
do that number of times that's the mode
um we'll get to the point of if you guys
like that back but i wanted to ask you
guys they bring back a new mode
you guys can probably pick up my tone
already
that you're leading the wizards
i don't care i don't care because they
give us a new game mode they do a
reworked iron banner and we're gonna see
it twice in the entire three month
season long
i'm not thrilled that for one that the
rotating the rift isn't going to be a
rotator even a rotator until season 18.
so somebody explained to me
why this is two weeks and for the only
piece of the season that this is in here
i got you baby girl don't worry about it
[Laughter]
or if or is anybody is anybody on my
team here of where you're not thrilled
that this is only like rift is in here
two weeks in the entire season
no
no one's on no one
let me kind of but i think that it's
fine the way i think okay i wish rift
was at least a little bit more
accessible but especially for the first
season i'm fine with the way that
they've laid it out
okay why
okay so first of all it's gonna make it
it's gonna make iron banner extremely
hyped like people like especially with
the rework especially with the new game
mode especially with the loot people are
gonna be extremely excited to jump into
iron banner and the population is gonna
be like
way higher than anything we've seen in
like a pvp mode in ages so there's gonna
be a ridiculous amount of hype around
iron banner everyone's going to want to
go play it everyone's going to want to
go try the new mode and if it was just
like a common thing that happens like
you know oh you know every couple weeks
we get to play rift you know if it's if
it's a more exclusive more rare thing it
makes the hype so much more elevated and
it makes it so much more coveted to
actually play iron banner it makes the
heart grow fonder ebontos
okay you don't think three years of no
new modes and no new maps is enough
distance to grow fonda i hear you
the argument does kind of irk me but i i
feel like it is going to make it
like really interesting and really like
it's going to get a lot of people into
the mode at the same time which is going
to be exciting
yeah i don't actually have a strong
opinion in here i just like seeing
eubantas get up yeah they just see them
upset yeah i don't have any strong
opinion about this oh yeah i just did it
i get you e i get you i i i what if you
were out of town for that week and then
you weren't able to get your iron lord
until
maybe next year i would look in a mirror
and say the word casual
and realize that maybe i should have
prioritized my life a little better okay
okay okay okay
you
these flights and these plane tickets
because i got to get this video game
title yeah
have you thought about having no life
outside of destiny if you feel casual
okay
like what if
when what if this thing maybe takes you
20 30 hours and you've got a crazy
schedule if you can't get it in two
weeks you can't even get iron lord and
then season it comes out
i got a x screen i got x cloud
i got to make it happen somewhere but
now look to your point i understand
where you're going with it
but it's kind of like here's the thing i
remember in d1 hey come on let's take it
back y'all let's all go to the time
machine let's go back to d1 hot tub
stuff
i remember yeah
i remember
i remember when
it they would make it rift or clash
right
and dude look it's this again like they
would get frustrated that it wasn't
consistently controlled right so i worry
that the newness of rift would wear off
on more of a consistent cadence because
let's be honest even though we're ha i
know i know i i have an opinion i have
an idea let's go don't go go go so
why is it that we've had iron banner be
controlled for like three years they've
already had the option to be like hey
what do we have like four iron banners
this season ballpark
control control control clash control
control control mayhem they already have
the ability and have for a long time to
mix it up why do you have to make it
only two and rift what if you had you
know a control rift control rift you
have the same cadence of them
but two of them were rift
but remember they made the statement
that they would never do
iron banner and trials again on the same
week
so trial still has to exist on those off
weeks based on the new case well i'm not
saying you agree with it but that's what
they say so the way i look at it is
off-week trials off week iron man and
then if they want the the live event
that we all hate for the people yeah i
was like the season
that everybody really was worried about
where i meet you in the middle is on a
seasonal event i don't got no problem
with it being there you know saying
that's just me but they they wanna it
seems like they wanna
differentiate each activity and give it
this special feel but i understand your
point if you look at it two weeks yeah
that's rough if you can't make it yeah
it's gonna it's gonna suck like you
can't get get stuff done
i don't in a weird way i don't feel as
strongly as i thought i would feel
against it i didn't think i was actually
going to be in the minority okay yeah i
didn't i didn't really think i didn't
really think
it
because let's be honored bro they've
been killing ben and like banner was the
band-aid for we ain't got no
was the six month season i get that that
was the six month season band-aid every
so i get that but
now we're in a point where you got a
little shorter story cadence you got
like four or five weeks whatever it's
going to be it feels like maybe the
season's longer who knows
um but i mean then what do you get for
the rest of the season
you get we're gonna have a dungeon which
will be cool but you know you're gonna
beat it you're gonna solo it all those
things will be a thing and yeah we're
gonna have the rotations for old raids
but i have my questions of the value of
those anyway
but it's the idea of
pvp has been asking for
something for so long
the map will be in rotation we'll get to
that in a second but it's the idea that
we get a new game mode and you get to
see it for two weeks of an entire season
and one of the things in jogaroth's long
21 segment twab was we're gonna have
multiple game modes next year this is
the first one we see and you get it
twice and that's just like for me i
guess
i don't know i would think the game mode
would be at least in the rotator as well
some i mean i know they're trying to
hype up iron banner but i don't know i
guess we'll see how it goes it's just to
me pvp has been asking for this for a
while and it didn't feel like enough but
maybe i'm in the minority maybe people
are going to be happy for the hype and
it's going to blow up the playlist who
knows and you i see where you go the
only thing the only encounter i have is
it is a week though
that's a full reset like you seven days
you you can't there's not one day you
could get on
that's it but i'm just saying you get
one week and maybe there's the dude who
gets to play on saturday
okay
and that's just like when he gets to
play destiny is casual he gets two
saturdays an entire season to experience
rift
and one's in week two and then the next
one's six weeks later and maybe he's
busy that saturday i'm just like
it's just not a giant window was my only
thing and i'm gonna like let it alone
now because apparently i'm in the
minority and it's fine i was just like
yeah
i just was kind of curious so
anyway i called it again so we got it i
got a couple to hear you i i think pvp
just needs more things in general like
this one this won't even be a
conversation if they actually made more
pvp cards like it was just like hey
new thing this season for pvp it's like
that's the first time we've said that in
as you said about a thousand days since
we've said a new thing for pvp this
season
uh but rift should be cool should be a
fun game i'll be very curious how it
plays with the new sandboxes the
abilities you got bubbles you got over
shields and super recharged i'll be
really curious how that all goes so
that'll be very interesting
uh is there anything you guys see
with regards to picking up the orb and
dunking it as being like
an epic strategy is everybody gonna run
transversive steps to sprint faster
like is there a point where you guys see
any anything already for rift that we've
got right now being advantageous to use
like the first week out
uh blink
i forgot about that
yeah i think you can't like while
carrying the orb
well i don't know is that gonna be a
thing we'll see
i don't think it was right now it says
one and d1 i i vividly remember using uh
twilight garrison to dash around and you
know well see the difference was d1 you
would like almost go like third person
you would like hold the orb wouldn't you
this one they say yeah the spark itself
is a buff that allows full weapon and
ability usage along usage aside from
super so you just won't be able to super
but abilities and weapons are in there
you can kill yeah you can kill with it
you're you're also um
way faster in d2 which i think is a
problem with this mode especially on the
existing maps so i'll be interested to
see how they solve that because
it could end up being way too easy to
score and not require enough strategy
especially since it's a buff what is it
but i really like it no it's just going
to show us like a like on the bottom
left-hand corner it's just going to show
like the little not an actual buffer
it's just going to say like rift holder
or something i'm sure
yeah i don't know how i feel about the
riff holder being able to shoot
i kind of missed the like the rugby
you know
and you got to get the assembly line
everybody hold me down
i kind of missed that i don't know how i
feel about that just yet
with their you know riff holder being
able to kind of do everything a noble
guardian can do except
super
you know i don't know if that's a stiff
enough pedal i don't know it just felt
weird because i kind of like like yo
hold me down so i can get it across the
five goal like you know this yard line
and just moving that ball you know i've
missed that aspect of it and then you
like the the backflip dunking it in the
wrong third person that was so cool yeah
so
i don't know i'm sure they've i'm sure
they've played tested and come up with a
system that at least works pretty well
so we'll have to see i i do
is probably gonna have to get uh turned
off for that oh
word
i didn't even think about that
yeah that sword if you if you pick up
heavy and be like fly all right i got
heavy i'm gonna
just like fly over there it's a wrap
yeah yeah
that's definitely gotta go
uh you can't hold the buff for too long
they did say that so you'll have to you
won't be able to like camp and like
hunker down so it may be the idea of
fighting but that's kind of one of those
things if you get a couple people
running with that like god to your
player and he's just like mowing people
down with a couple support i'll be i
don't know i'll be curious to see how it
plays because yes i'm with you i miss
the fact that like
you were the ball carrier and you needed
help to get there i did kind of like the
team the team yeah
we'll see this is just like slayer it
away you you just pick up a thing and
okay you're glowing but we'll see i'm
gonna be fair and wait to play it and
see it first
uh the other pc gets a new map
so this is the this is the thousand year
or the thousand year wait no thousand
day wait uh feels like it yeah the map
is called disjunction it is a
symmetrical map with a base on either
end three lanes with plenty of
crossovers they said it's got lanes for
short medium and long range style combat
and it is a
it is one of our largest maps yet they
state so with regards as you guys were
saying if it's built for rift
yep sounds like it that's what i was
gonna say yeah it's built for rift
specifically because it is longer as you
guys said the range to cover and
you're not going to have rift on anomaly
for example that would be just
ridiculous
unless the unless the thing that you
have to dunk is on the rotating
platforms that would be hilarious to try
and see people dunk on the middle of
anomaly
but do you think this map will be able
to come up outside of rift or do you
think it will be a rift-only map aka
we're not actually getting a new it's
going to be available i think
so they actually state it disjunction
will be available day one of season 17
for all 6v6 3v3 and free for all modes
and crucible as well as iron banners so
the map is
in the mix everywhere so you're good to
go there they're not limiting it to riff
so we'll get to experiencing it but iron
banner is weak too so rift is going to
be kicked off pretty quick as well
noise shout out to the thematic
map for the season i know we actually
got it isn't that like a great
pyramid ship map like it
matches what's going on in like wow
yeah right
after almost three years i'm just i mean
i know lord shax was dealing with supply
chain issues
but i'm just glad he was able to come
that and get a new map out the door i'm
just he finally got a shipment it's been
delayed for so long
they finally got the the microchips they
were waiting for they finally got him
yeah they needed the microphone
uh they've got some other crucible
changes uh they basically state
what was oh for like zone control
they're gonna bring that one back um as
well as kind of a thing
so they say that's gonna be all about
the time that you have capping the zones
versus the actual kills so it's all
about the objective play which might
make people better at capping the zones
as opposed to be like hey here's the
zone we need to capture why are you
running away happens all the time
uh elimination that one's basically
going to match the respawn time of
trials control is going to be the team
gains one point per participant when
capturing a zone rather than the flat
one point so now if you've got six
people you're gonna get six when you
actually cap a point so they seem to be
leaning a little more into objective
play which is probably not a bad thing
uh rumble the time limit's been
increased to 10 minutes i don't know if
i've ever had a rumble match go to time
because usually there's one person
kicking everybody's butt really fast so
i don't know why that's necessary but
maybe
uh mayhem points for super kills are
increased to three total score is up to
200 but they decrease the time mayhem is
just fun rooks that didn't shout i with
mayhem was just around because it's one
of my favorite ways to just like oh
absolute chaos let me go have fun for a
little while i love mayhem just to go
goof off for a bit i just wish it was
there always
uh gambit's doing some reputation
changes which i don't need to spend too
much time on that so that's just gonna
get updated they are updating the streak
system
which sounds more convoluted than it has
to be which is just weird
like why why this is but the idea is if
you spend like all your time in crucible
and you go do like hey your friends want
to run one strike it's not gonna
completely kill your crucible streak
it's gonna take it down one
but if you do like one strike and then
one crucible match and then one of the
other then yeah you're gonna be in a bit
of a mess but the idea is like if you
take a break for one thing and you come
back you only have lost one streak so
it's probably better also grand masters
are gonna have rejoin if you do get
error coded that's
god forbid probably a good thing
um they also have a giant cosplay thing
coming on
july 7th which is going to be bungie day
so we'll see more about that um over the
summer but they've got some really
high-end cosplayers going basically full
send for some cool stuff so i'll be very
curious what they do
but that is most of the twab outside of
some little random stuff um
so i kind of wanted to ask you guys as
most people are thinking
solar 3.0 we got iron banner coming
and then shadow you're kind of the first
one as you do mostly pvp generally
where did you
did you enjoy the season of the risen
did you play it that much or do you just
like knock it out and leave it are you
excited for the story lore or is that
anything that really like gets you going
for the next season
um
i'm not super into the lore i don't know
much about it um i i don't know i think
i would like to get into it a little bit
more in the future and just like with
pve in general i feel like i've kind of
neglected it a little bit and it's i
don't know i don't i don't give it
enough credit um but overall i am
definitely more pvp focused so i'm
excited for the pvp stuff that's coming
nice cool cool
gentlemen what about you guys what do
you
because i'm guessing the cadence next
week is going to be monday or tuesday
like teaser second 30 second little
twitter teaser then tuesday or wednesday
whatever the next day is we get the full
trailer day after that or same day if
like wednesday is going to be the
website reveal thursday is going to be
the giant twab maybe telling us about
solo 3.0 maybe there's a tease about the
story
where are you guys at with regards to
season 17 for
just like hype level are you excited for
it is any of this getting you ready
you're just like you've got to wait
until next week and then you're going to
be hype train full send where are you
guys at
i think it didn't hit me yet that um
you know it's it's
i don't feel this is a weird season for
me because i guess i was so wrapped up
with witch queen
that like you know caesar the risen was
kind of like after but it was cool and
then we kind of wrapped up quick
so it just feels like oh wow we're ready
for the new season already like i don't
know it's just a weird thing where i
felt like for the first time i know what
it is
it's coming off of the last season and
how long that was fair so i'm like oh
yeah this is how it used to be like
before how long was the drought with um
season of the long six month long season
but it was a three month extra push yeah
yeah that's what it was so i forgot like
oh yeah this is the cadence now so now i
got to get back in there finish up some
things i got to do but yeah i'm ready i
want to see where the marketing goes i
want to see what we're doing you know as
far as you know are we finally getting
this rasputin situation
what's going on what's going on in the
in my opinion the smaller sub story
that's going to hold off the major story
even though we want the major story yeah
we're getting there like we we gonna get
some in the corner secluded
self-contained
and obey something or whoever something
and and figure that out but um yeah i
i'm excited i want to see the marketing
they always do a great job with that i
want to see what the trailer hit and
then obviously which of the 3.0 is we
getting whether it be solar and how is
it going to affect then do i have to
dust off some solar legendaries to
synergize with uh you know some of this
new stuff so that's where i'm at with it
and that stuff is always exciting to me
so yeah i'm ready travis where are you
at trav are you kind of even keel until
next week
yeah i mean i
i tend to not really have time to get
that hype to these days because i'm
always busy with stuff and i'm as you
guys as we talked about before the show
uh i'm always excited when games get
delayed because i'm trying to catch up
constantly um
but uh i would say probably solar 3.0 is
the thing i'm most excited about that we
know about right now and uh but the
thing i'm always most excited about with
new seasons new content drops is the
stuff i don't know about yet so i hope
that they surprise us in some cool way
that i'm not expecting that's honestly
what i'm always here for so hopefully
they'll do something new and not just
give us a
six person matchmaker activity that
makes me want to die that's my hope so
uh yeah no that's probably fair it's i
i'm at the point to where
i know when the trailer drops the hype's
gonna go we all know bungie makes damn
good trailers the marketing team the
capture team who puts those together who
gets those shots they do a really really
good job even with the guardian games
trailer you see them get those little
like
they're very good at what they do for
marketing so i know the hype's going to
be there i think i'm with travis where
i'm looking for that one thing that i
don't expect
we expect a subclass we expect you know
a four to five week story if they do a
longer one
as long as it's you know not dragged out
if you you know feels good and the big
question as usual is going to be the
activity
i mean how many different ways are we
going to shoot the shoot the enemies in
the face this this season type thing
because we know that's what we do
but again is there going to be a little
mix-up to it and that's i think probably
the exciting point is
i know the bungie devs on twitter have
been very excited about the narrative
and i'm very curious what their hype
bungee yelling i'm so excited for you
guys to see the narrative tweets are all
about because i haven't seen the
narrative team
be this pumped and this vocal
theoretically on twitter in quite a long
time and i'm curious as to why
because either they're bringing a
character up that's going to be
you know a huge lead into lightfall
they're bringing you know some character
interaction that's gonna happen there's
like a big moment that's the stuff that
i'm curious to see because we we know
all the things around the systems are
gonna be there we know we're gonna be
playing the playlists more than we
probably prefer to we're gonna have to
do a little bit of pinnacle grinding
that stuff's there i'm pumped for the
dungeon i know i'm getting a dungeon so
it's gonna be figuring it out but it's
the the story surprise and then
hopefully one more surprise that we get
in the season i'm curious to see what
they do but
witch queen was very good risen actually
wasn't a dumpster of a season to go with
witch queen because we've had
questionable seasons with expansions the
last couple and this is the first time
they both hit
and i think that's where
with this momentum going into
you know this year i think this season's
gonna hopefully tell us a lot about what
this year looks like for destiny because
year five started off well now can it
keep it going
yep i agree well i i agree with your
point though
to see them that excited about the next
season is very intro usually they don't
get that level of hype unless it's an
expansion and to see them like so
clearly there's some story beats that
they're excited you know to to get into
so yeah we'll see what's that man yep
um but yeah that's mostly all i got man
shadow it has been an absolute pleasure
having you with us tonight thank you so
much for taking the time out i know
schedules can get busy and things we
appreciate the
carving out the two hours in the evening
for us but at this point basically what
i want to do is extend the floor to you
tell everybody where to find you what
you got cooking if you got a big video
in the works because
you have an insanely large channel for
not that many videos so everyone's a
banger so if you got an idea what what
the next one is cooking you know what we
can look forward to from you but
basically where can they find you what
can they expect and please everybody go
follow him
watch his content and if you want to be
a better crucible player he is one of
the better people who are going to make
you think differently about the game but
now the floor is yours
yeah so yeah thank you so much for
having me on it was good talking with
all you guys um
so the next video i'm working on is that
basically i went through the entire
history of the game since like destiny
won all the way up to current and found
like the most
the most hated and the most like
despised things that have ever happened
and i'm basically making a video about
all of those things um
so that that's going to be my my next
one
it's literally the thumbnail um
yes i have another i haven't i've a few
more big ideas on the horizon but we'll
have to see how that goes with the whole
new season i did mention previously um
about my sniper rifle tier list i'm
probably gonna do that again soon um
but yeah i'm excited um so you can you
can find me on youtube and twitch uh
shadow destiny and then my twitter and
instagram is ltz shadow
yes hello shadow destiny man
killed it man i love love what you did
brought a lot of energy great fresh take
spicy takes i like that i love the
intent man yeah it's really cool unique
i like the mythbuster stuff that was
done that video went insane
yeah like you killed that just i like
you you have a very unique approach to
your destiny card so i'm looking forward
to the the most hated stuff i want to
see prometheus lens in there i want to
see um the reign of the lord of wolves
that was that was a tough time
and even though lord was one of my
favorites but you know i'm dying to see
what you got in there but i salute to
you for pulling up coming through a lot
of fun man
travel anything for i guess
uh yeah um you can read my uh review of
trek deyomi uh which went live last week
or watch the video like cog did i i do i
do agree [ __ ] i think it was one of my
better ones
yeah thank you
um this week i'm working on um
evil dead the game as i as i mentioned
uh which i think comes out tomorrow so
we got late review codes but i'm going
to try to have it by end of next week
and other than that you can see a bunch
of content i'm making i made a destiny
raid guide if you still haven't done a
vow the disciple i think my guide's
pretty okay uh first first piece of
content i've worked on anything like
that and then i've got some previews of
games i can't talk about but you can
read all my stuff on ign.com
you can watch me argue
with a uh
a lawyer
ain's an industry veteran and a
puppet's corpse come to life named dan
um
yeah
that's on the bitcast show and uh yeah
you can follow me on twitter at ty guy
travis if you or you know add me on xbox
live playstation uh also tie guy travis
i'll i'll play with some people i try to
play with the community every once in a
while when i have time so i hit me up
for that and uh yeah love you guys still
looking forward to gcx even though uh
it's gonna be one of the most stressful
weeks of my life but uh you know i'm
feeling for you on that bro we're going
to talk we got yeah
what
no honestly uh real quick thank you for
the super chat rel uh spider dies and
comes back as a guardian that would be
quite a trick there's rumors of what
he's doing right now but yeah that would
be
they can do some crazy stuff we'll have
to see but uh no i just want to say
thank you shadow again for taking the
time awesome guest um
thank you for working our way through
the world of the skill based matchmaking
discussion
didn't mean to surprise me oh no happy
to have that's i mean that's honestly
what i would love to have like a civil
discussion of like let me get some like
all the different mindsets about skill
based i'd love to get like high level
pvp players on both sides just to have
that debate back and forth and just to
see but it's like it's good to get
the reasoning as to why and kind of the
debates going back and forth and that's
why we're here is like if we can't have
civil discussion then we're kind of
missing out on all of this and that was
um one thing that we were talking about
before as well is you know we're missing
the idea to have like discourse and
differing opinions and stuff like that
and that's a good thing that we're
always capable of having here which i'm
happy to see so just wanted to thank you
for coming on and yeah your content is
fantastic so keep doing what you're
doing and just ride that rocket ship as
high as it goes because you're
definitely going nowhere but up
thank you again appreciate it
well chad thank you guys for being here
chad has been on absolute fire tonight
if you guys are missing the if you're
not watching the show live we always do
this live on my youtube channel uh 7 p.m
eastern on thursday nights um next week
we're gonna have uh another pvp focused
gentleman castle coming on
so we've got um another interesting
discussion and next week's also going to
be massive hype for
well season 17. we're gonna have a lot
to talk about for sure so that will
definitely be coming up and then we are
getting close to 200 and i'm working on
something fun for 200 we'll see if it
can come together but either way you
guys have been here for a lot of
episodes and i just want to thank you
guys so anyways if you want to drop
likes on the video podcast if you want
to on spotify itunes or if you listen on
audio leave you know the high reviews to
help us the more ears that can see us
the better this goes so thank you very
much um i just appreciate all of you
guys my hosts and the guests thank you
for making this another awesome episode
so
for this episode for may 12th thank you
guys for all being here number 196
and one quick super chat right in the
end chris can we please get first curse
back i forgot that thing existed
first curse wow
all right well as we wrap this thing up
thank you guys very much and for this
episode it has been
the last word